Vanette close.
Are we close?
I'll be close.
All right.
Okay.
Oh,
sweet baby.
Jesus.
We uh,
live Gavin mcinnes first beer already
cracked,
dressed up like Michael Douglas and
falling down showing the briefcase.
Sean with a briefcase.
I got the exact briefcase he had.
Are those the same glasses he had
basically yet ray bans and I got him.
Normally detector would not wear a
pocket protector.
Correct?
No one wears him anymore.
But everyone in the movie has one.
Yeah.
Whenever you want to have a geek in a
movie,
like some sort of scientific character
science character,
he has to have a pocket protector.
Well,
I got all this on Ebay.
If you have some pre planning,
you can get a costume for like 10 bucks.
So this is a dollar 50.
You would have taken me months to find
this on the street.
Yeah.
How do you find a pocket protector?
Ebay.
Ebay,
Ebay and the tie,
I assume.
Is Yours the shirt?
Is that a your shirt?
Did you buy that shirt?
It's a great example.
I'm talking about,
I had to find this in New York.
It took me like two hours.
I had to go to a uniform supply store.
Huge pain in the ass.
I could've got it on Ebay or Amazon for
two seconds.
Yeah,
that's a weird kind of shirt.
A button up shirt with short sleeves
that you wear with a tie.
That's an odd look.
It's like I'm formal,
but I'm not because I need my forearms
free.
Yeah,
it's like La.
Everyone in that movie has one.
It's like an la business.
It guy back then back then,
now no one wears them anymore.
Now it's like like a like a hoodie
that's like an it guy where like a weird
tee shirt and a hoodie.
Like Jamie be dressed.
Exactly like Jamie.
Look,
that's what a Hoodie,
that's what a an it guy's dressed
meeting in the form too.
They all went at American apparel
sweatshirt.
Exactly.
Oh,
that's his own.
That's a Jamie Vernon special.
It says pull that shit up.
Yeah,
and you can get that@ayoungjamie.com
what does that mean?
Pull that shit up.
I always telling them,
whenever there's something going on in
the news or we're talking about
something,
we don't know what the answer is.
Like what is that?
Oh,
pull it.
Shut up Jamie,
and it'll find it up on youtube.
Huh?
Speaking to pull that shit up.
I liked this.
I like your,
your profile because I think you get
lumped into like a lot of like really
fucked up crazy people because you've
got some controversial ideas.
But I like what you did.
I liked this pro west pro gun pro life
pro gay pro Israel pro trump,
anti Nazi.
I don't know what Antifa is.
I see it all the time.
I'm sure you can explain it to us.
Uh,
anticensorship antifeminist anti Islam.
He leave your heart on your sleeve.
You've got it all.
It's really handy to do that.
I just did that about a week ago.
But in this day and age,
we're in a weird era where it's like a
philosophy age.
We're all Romans all of a sudden,
like socrates sitting here
philosophizing.
And you kind of have to make everyone
know exactly where you stand on this
spectrum.
Because if you're slightly right of
center,
your alt right and your go,
no,
those guys hate me but I hate these guys
so I'm right.
You're pro gay.
Yeah.
I think gays are just,
you're born gay and the idea that I
know,
I know I've,
I lived in the city since I was 18 so
I've been around gays for a quarter
century and I think of these guys I know
that had been together for 10 years and
I go,
so let me get this straight.
This,
these two are going to break up
according to you and evangelical person
and then they're just going to make out
with some chick with blonde hair and eat
her out
and like fucker and have a boner and
pray to God.
Come on.
You'd know that won't happen.
I,
I wonder how much of homosexual behavior
could be induced by molestation and
early age though.
Yeah,
that's the million dollar question
because that seems to be a real factor.
It's not,
and this is not the nine people that are
born gay,
but I think there's a spectrum and I
think there's most certainly some gay
acts that are committed on young people
and horrifically those people tend to on
a a pretty frequent basis do the same
thing to other young kids,
young kids.
Really Weird in,
in,
in terms of like the victims becoming
the victimizer.
Yeah.
I know where you're going with this.
We're walking into the elephant in the
room,
but what kind of,
not even mean just just talking about,
I was listening to the George to Chi
interview today because they're trying
to pull up everybody now that the Milo
thing is out there,
they're pulling up everybody who in any
way it has condoned sex with underage
people.
And George to Kai was talking about his
own experiences in camp and it was on
the stern show and he was just talking
about what he,
the way he was describing it as a
positive experience with a kid who was
in his late teens,
I think he said he was 19 and he was
like 13 somewhere in that age.
And you know,
it's absolutely child molestation.
It's absolutely illegal.
But the way he was describing it,
he was pretty much describing it as a
positive experience,
right?
Which when it's your experience,
I mean,
it's illegal.
The guy did something that was against
the law.
But boy,
that's a weird area because it's his
experience.
And he was talking about,
yeah,
well here's the deal and this is a
mistake Maiello made.
You have to acknowledge that what you're
talking about is fucked up and horrible
and wrong,
but you just so happen to have not had a
bad experience within those parameters.
Like say you were raped as a woman and
you came,
right?
Uh,
which by the way happens for some
strange reason.
So if you're one of those women in,
you're about to say that you have to
understand that we're going into a very
dangerous place right now.
And you can't say,
look,
some rapes are absolutely fabulous,
and women have come from them.
You have to say,
this is fucking horrible.
Rape is evil.
But I buy some weird freak of nature
actually liked,
or a murderer.
I'm sure there's times when you murdered
a guy and he ended up,
he was a mass murder and it was a good
murder.
Right?
And you go,
okay,
this,
I'm describing a murder.
I'm not condoning murder.
But in this weird case it worked.
And Milo's mistake was he said it worked
for me.
And then he implied that it could work
for a ton of other gays to be fucked at
13.
Well he did that,
um,
drunken peasants podcast and his take on
it from the drunken peasants was
different than his take on it from mine.
And on my podcast it seemed more like he
was trying to make light of something
that most likely definitely did happen
to him.
The father,
Michael.
Yeah.
So there's two,
there's the father Michael thing,
and I don't know if I believe that.
I think that's just a,
I've heard him say that joke a few times
where he's like,
I'd never would've given such good head
if it wasn't for Father Michael.
Right.
So you think that might be something
like that he's constructed?
I don't believe it.
I don't know why.
That's just my gut.
And then the other thing was condoning
sexual relationships with 13 year olds.
And he said,
especially in the gay world,
now I know of straight guys who were a
strict,
I'm thinking of in particular who was
molested at camp and it was by an older
gay camp counselor.
This guy thinks of that guy every day,
falls them on Linkedin,
hoping he'll die.
He wants to murder him.
Uh,
so the problem with what Milo said is
you end up normalizing this behavior and
say it's okay if in the gay world,
next thing you know,
some older gay who's at Camp Goes,
well,
this is probably a fag that I'm blowing.
Right?
So this is,
okay.
Yeah.
So what I say to these gays,
these 13 year old gates to go,
I would be okay with fucking a 29 year
old.
I go,
well,
I'm sorry,
but we're not normalizing that because
the vast,
vast majority of times it doesn't turn
out well.
So No.
Yeah,
that's a very good way of putting it,
you know,
and it's,
it's really disturbed.
Well done.
The Milo thing is so odd because first
of all,
I think he's got this act and let's call
it an act cause part of it has got to be
an act.
He's got a wide spectrum of his
personalities.
So on Bill Maher he can be a raging
liberace queen with pearls on dress like
a woman.
I mean just like a woman.
Yeah.
Camper than any woman I know.
And then for the apology,
he's the conservative with the coke
bottle glasses.
Yeah.
It's sorta like when a Jamaican goes
back to Jamaica and they start speaking
in Patois,
like their grandmother and not
necessarily lying.
It's just a wide range of use.
Yeah.
He plays it up and there it,
there's definitely a performance piece
to a lot of what he does.
What's,
what's really interesting is he's very
good at riling people up.
He's obviously very good at getting
people upset and,
and in doing so,
he's created these sort of false
narratives about him,
that he's a Nazi,
that he promotes genocide.
I mean,
there was so many people outside the
Berkeley thing that were screaming,
calling them a Nazi and saying he's a
fascist when they in fact were behaving
in very authoritarian fascist ways.
That's Antifa by the way,
you said,
I don't know what Antifa is.
That's those guys antifascist is that
what Antifa stands for?
But you're right,
they're terrorists and they use terror.
They use violence to achieve political
gains,
which terrorism and these people,
it's not like Milo ever set or trump
even ever said anything that is remotely
close to genocide,
but those guys just go.
Anyone that wants to enforce immigration
laws is a fucking Nazi.
So I need violence cause I'm trying to
stop Hitler.
I'm around the first stages of Hitler,
so I'm going back in time and strangling
him in his crib.
Right,
right.
But the problem is the way they're
reacting to it is the absolute wrong way
to react to someone who sang something
that you don't agree with.
Oh yeah.
The the right way is to say something
that you feel opposes what they're
saying and makes more sense to debate
them.
That's the beauty of free speech,
like w it has no limits.
If you want to get out there and deny
the Holocaust,
you want to get out there and sexualized
toddlers all go to your talk.
I want to hear it.
Then in the q and a,
I'll shoot you down.
Well not,
I don't think he even should just be a q
and a.
I mean I think it should be real clear
other there.
There should be someone and we shouldn't
just rely on the audience to come up
with some sort of a response.
I think if you're going to have someone
as controversial as Milo and you are so
opposed to it that you're willing to
throw bricks through starbucks windows
and light cop cars on fire,
there should be someone that can speak
for your side and then you should
organize some sort of a talk.
But this is setting it up the wrong way
because you go,
it's like someone said to me once,
hey man,
you know,
like we were talking about martial arts
falls,
black belt.
I'd fucking kick everybody's ass.
No,
you wouldn't.
First of all,
you wouldn't because you'd have
discipline and you'd realize the
consequences of that.
But second of all,
when you just kick someone's ass,
they don't,
they don't just take it like they come
back with a bat or a gun or their
brother,
he started fighting.
They want to get it back and it goes
back and forth and back and forth.
And all conflict pretty much goes that
way.
You have conflict and then someone
responds to that conflict and it
escalates.
So if you have this thing where you
start throwing bricks through windows
and light and cop cars on fire in
stopping people from talking and hitting
people that have a make bitcoin great
again,
hats and just see that girl got maced in
the face by a 60 year olds.
Eventually people show up with guns.
That's what happens.
And this is what happens when you keep
escalating the violence.
You become a them,
you become the other,
you become the enemy and you create this
polarizing atmosphere that's so intense
that no dialogue's kind of fix it now
because you're the enemy.
We,
you're talking about the north versus
the south.
You're,
you're talking about,
you know,
the,
the Protestants versus the Catholics,
you,
you create this horrific environment
where almost it's almost impossible to
avoid violence.
Well,
so I'm done avoiding it.
I'm taking the low road.
I'm punching them in the face.
So that's what you're doing with this
outfit?
Yes.
That is really what I'm doing with this
outfit.
I did a talk at Nyu.
They pepper sprayed me.
Did they re when was this?
This was a couple of weeks ago.
What did,
what was it talk about?
I didn't even have a plan.
They know me as pro trump or something
and they,
the,
I'm a Nazi because of that.
They sh they don't want to give a
platform to free speech.
That's the irony of all this is they
pretend that it's gotten so far.
It's beyond debate now in their world.
We are recruiting fascists for some sort
of imminent genocide.
So we're like signing up the brown
shirts with a form at our talks and you
go say that was possible.
Uh,
how does that work?
Like we sign you up,
then you're part of the club.
Then you come with us on the next
genocide.
The fuck are you talking about?
You haven't played it through in your
mind because for these people it's a
religion.
That's why they don't want to debate.
It's like a born again.
He doesn't want to debate about the
existence of God.
He's already on that side.
So what was your plan when you went
there?
What did,
what did you want to talk?
I was going to say,
uh,
this Nazi that,
that you've made Milo and I out to be
who wants genocide and who,
uh,
sees nonwhites is inhuman,
blah,
homophobic,
sexist,
whatever.
Uh,
first of all,
that guy should be allowed to talk if he
existed,
but he doesn't exist.
Your monster is a mythical beast and
you've gone to college,
you're 60 grand in debt already to fight
this mythical beast who doesn't fucking
exist?
Well,
in terms of Milo,
he definitely doesn't exist.
Milo is not a Nazi.
He's definitely,
he's not promoting genocide.
And those are two things that just get
trumpeted about left and right.
Exactly who is.
But Milo has said some very inflammatory
things about and in a very generalizing
way about women and about the wage gap
and about all sorts of things that he
designs his words and his phrases to be
inflammatory.
So he gets the most response and it's
been incredibly profitable.
I mean up into Harper Collins pulled his
book deal.
He had a $250,000 book advance.
His book was number one on Amazon.
Just sheerly through controversy.
Yup.
I mean through presales and controversy.
So it's a strategy and a lot of ways and
it's also a response to this really hard
stance that the far left is taking this
anti anti free speech stance.
Right.
But always with these cases you go,
what exactly did he say?
I always say this to people who bitch
about it and I told her,
I go,
what sentence in what book is factually
incorrect?
What specifically are you saying?
And with this Milo thing,
he said that often sexual relationships
with 13 year olds can be beneficial for
gays.
Uh,
he has since retracted that and
apologized,
but that's not enough.
And that's about as as egregious as it
gets.
The other stuff that he says we all say
in a joking way and then that becomes
pure evil and you advocate for this,
right?
So the left is willfully ignorant of
humor when it comes to Milo and with
trump too,
like the grab the pussy thing,
which they had a whole fucking parade
about and they still wear these dumb
wool hats to look like a pussy,
which is a joke you said on a bus,
you're wearing a dumb joke on your head.
Uh,
they,
they know that he doesn't want to have a
new policy called the pussy grabbing
statute,
but they are willfully hiding their
sense of humor so they can take things
literally and go off on a tirade of it.
Well,
I think they're shocked that we've been
fed our entire life po politicians that
speak in a statesmen Lee like way a very
predetermined,
planned out way where they have pauses
in their speech like Obama,
when he speaks,
he has some very non normal patterns to
his behavior.
Yeah.
Like those,
those things that people do.
The showmanship of being a president,
that it's all designed to comfort you
and have you think that this person is
clearly different than anyone.
You know,
they talk different,
they have better speaks president
beaches,
they have better speaks.
They,
they're,
they're statesmen like,
you know,
they,
they speak in these,
uh,
preplanned out sentences that are
articulate and,
and,
and cleanly worded.
And that's not what you get with trump.
And that disturbs the shit out of
people.
It just serves it.
Like,
I saw so many people going off the other
day about his talk about uranium and
Hillary Clinton's selling uranium.
You know,
how it's things and you,
it's for things very bad.
Things like he's running out of words.
She doesn't know what the words are.
You know,
that doesn't necessarily mean anything,
but people are pointing to it like it's
this horrible moment where this
president,
essentially all he did was run out of
words and just the fucking guys probably
working 16 hours a day,
that's probably exhausted.
I mean,
the overwhelming stress of the job for
any one of them is almost immediately
apparent once they get into office.
And you're seeing it with trump as well.
You're seeing like,
like that unhinged press conference that
he made guarantee you.
Some of that has to do with the fact
that guy has worn the fuck out.
You know,
he's a 70 year old man,
like I'm almost 50 and I'm fucking tired
all the time.
How's this guy who's 20 years older than
me?
Can I deal with the stress of running
the biggest economy,
the biggest military,
the most insane country the world has
ever known.
Yeah,
I mean that's what the United States is.
Yeah.
They say Maggie Thatcher slept four
hours a night,
four hours a night repeatedly starts to
chip away at your psyche.
Oh yeah.
But the thing I would say about trump
when they say he's not presidential is I
tried that,
I tried it with Romney.
You got mad at his binder comment.
I,
I tried it with cruise,
the constitutional superman and who
could debate anyone and was area died
and and presidential.
And you went,
no,
he's ugly.
So I said,
okay,
I'm bringing in Rodney dangerfield from
caddyshack and he's just going to be a
wrecking ball.
And when Huffington Post says we're
putting trump in the entertainment
section,
said of the new section,
Romney and cruise wouldn't have said
anything.
Trump says,
ann coulter points this out in your
book.
In trump,
we trust jump goes,
uh,
Arianna Huffington.
Didn't your husband leave you for a man?
Yeah,
I think he made the right choice.
I think it was a very good choice.
And I go that you,
you brought this on yourself.
You made me have to get him.
Well,
what she's doing,
you know,
within culture is doing is very similar
to what Milo's doing.
You mean there,
there are merchants of outrage and
that's what they're doing.
I disagree.
I think they're speaking in a hyperbolic
tone.
They're flamboyant,
but that's what the charter was still
there.
Yes.
There's,
there's definitely some truth,
especially with Milo that some of the
things that he says,
um,
but all truth.
What,
what?
Like again,
I'm saying it right now.
What,
what did he say this factually
incorrect?
Well,
that wasn't a joke.
Not,
not factually incorrect,
but extremely offensive to people like
the 13 year old boy comment.
Like the thing about sort of normalizing
relationships between grown men and 13
year old boys.
Right.
You know,
I think a big part of why he even says
that is because he's in many ways like a
natural contrarian and in many ways a
guy who wants to get a rise out of
people.
And by saying that he didn't feel like
there's any consequences to being
outrageous in that regard.
But I think we could both agree whether
or not it's factual.
In his case
it's a fucked up thing to say right at
the fucked up thing to say it was
negligent,
which is why I apologize.
But I think the grain of truth to that
and with his other statements is a lot
more than a grain,
but the grain of truth to what he was
saying,
his gaze have less chastity than
straights.
And if a woman is known as a slut,
she's less likely to be picked up.
And I've been sued for calling woman a
slut.
Where are you really?
Yup.
Who Sued you?
It was a long time ago.
Back in vice days it was in do's and
don'ts.
And the,
the way the law is,
it's kind of antiquated,
but it's like,
oh,
you called her a slut now she won't have
currency in the market of marriage.
Well,
because she's known as a whore,
so we're going to punish you punitively
for this sin.
Did you have to settle?
Yeah.
God dammit.
You can't even call someone a slut.
There's no word for a man.
No,
I cad.
That's a compliment.
That's hilarious.
Yeah.
A cat is hilarious.
Well,
the fact that there's no equivalent for
a man shows you that there's a different
standard.
And then with gays it is different to
like 13 year old and an older person,
right?
If it's a girl and a 40 year old
teacher,
I want to take him to the parking lot
and beat him till he's has a weird,
he walks weird for the rest of his life.
If it's a woman in a boy,
uh,
I don't want to murder her.
I'm grossed out 13,
especially 14 little better.
And then with gays,
uh,
well I'm not gonna make the same mistake
Milo made right now.
Don't ever do it.
But if a guy's known as a slut in the
future,
like say a 19 year old fucks,
200 people as a woman,
no one wants to go near as a gay.
You've been around the block.
Yeah,
it's not,
this is not the same consequences for
sure.
And I,
I had a bit of my act about,
I don't know if you remember this
commercial,
but there was a commercial adjust for
men commercial where there was a baby
that was driving a porsche,
a baby with a beard and there was a
grown woman next to the baby and the
baby has like a Tuxedo on and it's like
you've always wanted the biggest bed,
his beard and the baby goes to the
nightclub and a bouncer looks at him a
winks.
And I'm like,
look at this,
look at this commercial.
[inaudible] see the babies.
Yeah.
So the baby walks in just for men.
I mean,
I dunno what the fuck just for men,
if you don't know it is some stuff that
guys put in their beard when they're
getting old.
So this baby's got a bottle,
he goes out to the dance.
For this.
All these girls with these tiny little
skirts dancing around him and he's like,
he's like a pimp and he's with this hot
woman.
And this to me,
my bit was this is proof,
positive proof,
positive.
There's no sexual equality when it comes
to child molesting.
Cause if you even wrote that down with
the sexist reversed,
if you wrote it down,
you're fucking going to jail.
Okay.
There's a little baby girl and she goes
out to a room full of guys who are
wearing Tarzan skirts and they're all
swinging dicks around her and she's got
a bottle and they're all fighting for
her attention and kissing her on the
cheek.
You would go to fucking jail.
But that was a commercial that aired on
mainstream television.
No one cared about it.
That commercial aired for years.
It's probably still on now.
And that commercial is proof positive
that we have a completely different
attitude towards a grown woman who's hot
as fuck and a little baby.
Yeah,
well even I was watching big with the
kids the other day.
Tom Hanks is what?
Eight in that movie?
Nine and then that woman's seduces him
and I guess he fucks her.
He gets a boner and I'm like,
you're raping a child.
Exactly.
Why are we watching?
And she's hot.
She's hot and he looks like a man.
So I'll just let it ride.
If that movie was reversed and it was a
young girl that all of a sudden was in a
sexual woman's body and the guy was
fucking her,
she's like,
I don't know.
Are we supposed to be doing this?
You would be horrified.
You would be absolutely horrified.
I've been arguing about cause of the
Milo thing when arguing about all this a
lot and I've been getting from gays and
guides with kids that are young.
Uh,
this whole thing about how they,
they keep saying,
come on,
don't lie.
You would definitely want to fuck a 13
year old girl if she was hot.
And I go,
I don't know where this became a normal
sentence.
I fucked 17 year olds when I was 17 it
was the worst sex.
I remember that.
And you'd be on top of her and is out.
You didn't even know when it was in.
Nobody do what was going on.
Yeah.
It's not like they go,
yeah,
fuck it.
Aw.
They didn't like it until they were like
26 I want pendulous breasts.
I want a divorce.
Say with a neck pendulous,
like worn out just for pencils.
Hey,
hanging.
Hanging low for I want,
I want to look like Cox when she's on
all and I want to see them.
Actually I don't want to see them swing
cause I'll come if I look at this.
Oh come on.
I'm not talking about like a orange in a
sock.
Oh,
I mean like it's got meat there,
but they droop you like when you're
fucking her from behind.
They go and they've experienced life
circles.
Yes.
They've experienced.
When I want to play tennis with a
toddler.
You want to play tennis with somebody
who can return a serve.
Yes.
Good point.
Yeah.
I don't know.
Get that.
Yay.
Come on.
You never been attracted to a 15 year
old girl like I don't,
I really don't get that.
But I know I was molested by a woman
when I was 13 years old.
Oh Shit.
When I was 13 years old,
there was a woman that we used to play
softball with on our block and
apparently she did it to a lot of boys
and she took me up to her room.
She played me some really good music.
She introduced me to a lot of led
Zeppelin.
She introduced me to comfortably numb
floyd this day.
When I think about that song,
I think about making out with her,
but she was 21 and I was 13 she just
kissed you?
No,
she grabbed my dick but I was just so
little fuck I was doing now.
No,
I was so confused.
I was 13.
I was like a little boy,
you know,
if she had caught me like a year or two
later,
I probably would have fucked her.
But that at that stage I was baffled
because I had like zero sexual
experience.
And then all of a sudden a woman,
a 21 year old woman with tetes of smoked
cigarettes and she was making out with
me and taking me up to a room is really
weird.
And she had a boyfriend and her
boyfriend was a construction worker and
he was a man.
I remember seeing him like on the job,
he has his shirt off and had a hairy
chest.
I was like,
what in the fuck?
And that was her boyfriend,
but she was just a wild woman.
And she uh,
apparently like taking young boys that
didn't know what they're doing and
taking them up to her room.
You know,
this is why we have judges cause there's
different cultures,
different genders,
different circumstances.
Every time I talked to a black guy about
their first sexual experiences,
my hair is whitened.
Why?
It's always like,
yeah,
I just fucked my cousin when I was 12
like Chris cotton was talking about
fucking his cousin was Chris Cotton,
comedian guy,
dark as a piece of coal,
uh,
fucked his cousin's Shirad small fucked
his babysitter when he was like 11 or 12
stories before.
I've heard the babysitter story before
where it's like,
you know,
you're 13 she's 18 and next thing you
know you're making out with her and
Ollie,
she's horrible,
but should she go to jail for 15 years?
Well,
that's a big,
there's a big difference between an
eight year old,
18 year old boy rather,
and an 18 year old girl and a 13 year
old girl and a 13 year old boy.
There's a just a big goddamn difference
if you're a grown woman and a 13 year
old boy.
Like,
here's the thing,
here's the big one,
and this is like,
this is,
this was one of the things that came up
in the Milo,
a conversation to where he was saying
that it's not that big a deal if a man
grabs a woman's tit and she doesn't want
them to.
I'm like,
well,
that's sexual assault.
If a woman grabs my dick and I don't
want her to,
that might be sexual assault,
but I'm not in danger.
You know what I'm saying?
It's like she's not going to fuck me up.
She's not going to rape me.
And that's where it gets different.
Like I'm not scared.
Like if a woman came over and grabbed my
ass like that,
you probably shouldn't do that,
but I'm not scared of you.
You know?
So,
um,
but if a man does that to a woman and
he's willing to violate our space like
that,
a woman has a real fear,
there is a possibility what the,
the door might be open it,
this guy could rape her.
Right.
And this all comes down to the myth of
equality.
And this is why the right is more,
has a more benevolent society than the
left.
The,
and I've noticed this with girls.
I've always said you can hit a woman if
she hits you 12 times,
that includes punches in the face.
So you just sit there going,
one,
two,
three,
12 and then 11 12th and then one I can't
even hit one.
If they hit me 12 I'd have to arm drag
her,
take her back.
Choker,
you could choke.
A crazy woman is trying to kill you,
but you can't punch 12 I would only do
it if I thought they were hurting
someone in my family.
Well,
when I talked to a feminist and liberals
about this,
they go 12 one and I go,
what?
Why?
It's,
you know,
we're stronger than you,
right?
They don't want to admit that.
They don't to admit that.
And it's the same with gays and it's the
same like I was writing about.
You remember that documentary dog fight
dwg and I'm looking at that.
That was Kimbo slice is in that and I'm,
I'm done on two dot.
A 5,000 a 5,000 and a I'm looking at it
going,
you guys were murdering each other on
the streets.
You figured out a way to solve it with
fights,
backyard fighting.
You shouldn't have the same enforcement
as rich white kids doing it in the
suburbs.
Or at least that's what your instincts
are when you see that.
Now that doesn't make sense.
The laws should be equitable across the
board,
but you go,
this is a different situation.
They're in a shitty situation.
They're murdering each other,
these backyard fights.
Sure someone loses an eye,
but they're not murdering each other
anymore.
It's an improvement.
And you go,
I don't know how to enforce this.
I don't know how it's done,
but you feel like there should be
different,
lots of different people.
And when you say we're all exactly the
same,
well the next thing you know,
women are getting punched one on one and
they're not as strong as men.
So they're getting fucking beating them.
Or you're telling women they're
invincible,
they're going out and getting shit faced
like you and I do.
And you go,
no,
you,
you're a Lamborghini.
You can't get wasted.
Your delicate,
I'm a fucking cheap old,
57 Chevy beat me up.
Right,
right,
right.
Well,
there's,
there's a narrative,
um,
whether or not people are aware of it,
but there is something that is actually
being thrown around as being a viable
narrative.
And that is that there's no biological
difference between men and women.
There's no biological difference between
the sexes and it,
when you see people say it,
it's,
I saw it,
there was a debate that Jordan Peterson
had.
Uh,
and one of the PR,
the people that he was debating was a
professor from the University of Toronto
and it was a gender equality professor
or something along that,
some bizarre discipline.
And I think it was a transgender man.
Like she was born a woman and then she's
a man or maybe,
yeah,
I,
I'm,
I'm pretty sure it's,
I'm not sure,
but it seems like it anyway,
it's a very feminine man.
Whatever it is.
And it seems like a woman that became a
man and it,
she,
he,
whichever how Z,
Z,
z.
Um,
and literally arguing,
knowing that this is going to be
broadcast,
knowing this is going to be on
television,
on the Internet,
saying that there's no difference.
There's no biological basis.
And like,
that's insane.
There's,
there's no difference between men and
women.
It is absolutely insane.
It's absolutely insane.
There are no women who come anywhere
near what men power lifters can do.
They don't come anywhere near,
they might be stronger than you or I,
they might.
They might cause they're doing it for a
long time and had taken steroids,
but even the women who take steroids,
there are no where near as strong as the
men.
It's not even close.
There's no women who are in the NFL.
There's no women heavyweight boxing
champions.
They're never going to beat the men.
There's,
there's an absolutely a biological basis
and sex.
I have trained extensively with women in
martial arts extensively.
There is an enormous difference and how
hard they hit.
There's an enormous difference in how
strong they are.
I feel like I could beat them up.
There's a lot of would fuck you up.
I'm just like,
I couldn't beat Ronda Rousey,
but I feel like I could beat up the
base.
No,
a lot of feathers weighs,
most of them would fuck you up,
but it's just a technique thing.
You know,
if if you had trained as long as them,
they would be in trouble.
It's just there's a lot of factors
didn't.
Yes.
Well,
I got in Shit for saying it because
there was a man who transitioned to a
woman after 30 years of being a woman
after fathering a child,
being in the military,
the whole deal,
go on living life as a man,
became a woman for two years and then
started having mma fights with women and
not telling them that he was a woman for
30 years.
She was a woman for 30 years and then
became a one.
I'm like,
that's fucking crazy.
And that the structure of the body's
different,
the hips are different.
The jaws different than the size of the
hands is different.
The size of the fist is an enormous
difference between the hour that a man
can generate.
When I see that trainee pounding the
living shit out of a woman,
it's like domestic violence.
Disturbing.
Yeah.
I,
I've,
I see it on the TV and I go,
there you go,
liberals.
There's your utopia.
What do you think?
And that's the problem with their
utopia.
It keeps making things worse and worse
and worse for them.
Yes.
Like even abortion and immigration in
Canada,
now they're,
they're pouring all these Indians in
like pancake batter and a Indians prefer
to have boys than girls and they're
starting to have gender based abortions
where they go,
I don't want to have a boy.
I mean I go to hanging out around here.
I'm good.
Let's keep aborting till we get a boy.
And you go,
Hey Lena,
is that real?
Yeah,
he liberals,
it's,
it's mostly the immigrants,
but you know,
it's the beginning of ethnic genocide
and you go,
hey feminists,
you're pro choice shit is getting you
fucking killed.
What?
That wasn't,
they're going to become the next
retards.
That wasn't the,
you know,
the reason why they wanted it in the
first place.
They just wanted the right to choose.
They want someone to tell them,
and particularly in the most extreme
cases,
like if a woman's raped,
like if a woman's raped and she gets
pregnant,
she should not have to keep that baby.
They're taking right exceptions.
But that is the freaking second that I'm
sick of freak exceptions.
Defining policies.
Okay,
but would you be,
would you be fine with those freak
exceptions being law?
Like if you're,
you,
you're a pro life person,
right?
That's your stance.
Sure.
Okay.
Um,
would you be pro choice of a woman was
raped?
I'm not doing that anymore.
No.
What do you mean I'm not playing that
game anymore?
Okay.
Well I'm not trying to play it in what
they do.
I know,
I know.
Other side of that is that your
daughter,
they always,
inevitably,
especially with journalists,
I'll be talking about sexism,
blah,
blah.
And they'll go,
what if your daughter was blah,
blah,
blah?
And I go,
you're trying to make me irrational.
Okay,
but I'm not accusing you of this.
But it's like these liberals have these
tricks where like what if a girl was
raped by her father and she got pregnant
and I looked it up.
I could only find one case,
one case in America of a father
impregnating a daughter.
And I thought this freak occurrence
keeps defining the whole debate.
We've got kermit Gosnell killing 40,000
babies that were in their third
trimester yet.
This one man is who's a,
he was the guy,
he's,
he's a,
he was arrested for performing a late
term abortion from abortions and they
discovered that it was a,
sorry 40,000 is my personal estimate of
the whole country,
but I think he did hundreds and
hundreds.
Now I understand what you're saying that
you don't want to get roped into any
crazy sort of hypothetical scenario
where you say,
what if it was your daughter and she was
raped by some convict to just got to
that.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
I know you don't want to get into that,
but in,
in certain circumstances,
I really think there's a,
there's,
there is,
uh,
a difference between someone who's
pregnant for three weeks and someone was
pregnant for five months.
There's a big difference.
Yeah.
Like with the ocean,
I just want to get it,
get it away from 17 weeks.
Like I want to get it down.
I want to get the whole argument down to
eight weeks,
eight weeks.
My goal.
Okay.
So my,
I have friends in New York City where
everyone has to think outside the box
and they're all like,
yeah,
it's murder and I'm for it.
Like Jim Goad says that all the time.
Anthony Kumina says that it's murder and
I think it's awesome.
Well,
that's because he doesn't want to be
responsible and he,
he fucks a lot of crazy girls.
That's really the problem.
I mean,
I've been to super fortunate that the,
the person that I had babies with,
I love.
Yeah.
I mean,
[inaudible] uh,
is got to take a lot of blame for this
shit he got in recently.
We all told him to get the fuck away
from her and he kept walking back into
the client's fun and I would see him
with her and it was like a fucking rape
victim being with their rapists.
Like I go,
oh,
what is that doing here?
And she left thigh high stockings.
Ooh.
Time to fuck.
I can get you a five year old.
No,
no,
not fun.
He,
I have a friend,
my friend Tony,
Tony's Zara from Columbus,
Ohio.
Good Buddy.
Of Mine,
who's a great guy,
but he's,
he's also a wise man.
And uh,
he has had this theory about psychotic
and erotic until almost the,
to basically almost that's true,
interchangeable,
that they sort of rotate on each of this
access.
And that when you get,
like we've all had gals from the past,
there were just like,
Whoa,
you know,
you'll leave their apartment and go,
Holy Shit,
I gotta take a shower.
I got to cool down jasmine.
Yeah.
And then they start calling you later,
like,
come over and fuck my mouth.
Like what?
Jesus Christ,
like the crazy ones,
the ones who want you to take a teaspoon
and scoop the come off their face so
they can get,
and this is only going to happen once in
my entire life,
but here we go.
And those girls exist and some of them
are really fun.
And when you're a guy and you're used to
girls that are like,
no,
don't come in my mouth.
No,
don't touch me there.
I'm not going to.
You know there's like some,
so many people are so reserved and so
restricted and so,
so confined and then you date some crazy
girl and she's just wild.
She's like put it in my ass.
You're like,
Whoa,
where are we going with anthony?
She was that and then some and already
was like framing little kids who were at
the house.
I think she got one of them got marker
on them and or she,
she put sparkles in his hair or
something and the mother goes,
what the hell is going on with your hair
you've got that's going to take forever
to get out.
And she goes,
it was her and blamed some 10 year old,
no evils dark shit she had done.
But that being said,
so that's going too far.
But I do agree wholeheartedly.
And when my friends tell me they dumped
some bitch cause she's crazy,
I get mad at them because I go,
you crazy.
Pitches are the best sex you'll ever
have in your life.
If she's not calling the cops then he
fucking her.
But that's what you're hypocritical
then.
Cause that's anthony.
That's the gun.
It's the balance gets to the point where
they call the cops.
Sex should be right before that.
You should see the judge in the room
floating above your head with the gavel
like,
uh,
see,
nobody wants to say that.
And there is a reality.
And here's another reality.
It's super uncomfortable reality.
And this is,
I want to just get real clear about
this.
This is in no way condoning any form of
rape or any form of sexual assault or
any form of doing anything to anyone,
male or female against their will.
That said,
there are women who undeniably have rape
fantasies.
Yes.
So what's that?
Margaret Atwood talks about that and she
says,
yes,
but in our rape fantasies,
it's not a guy with a ski mask who jumps
out of a Bush fat and ugly.
It's Mr clean and he's cleaning our
house and then he says,
Hey,
I want to make love to you and you're
going,
no,
no level of law.
But that's her though.
Some,
some women,
it's a guy comes in with a gun and makes
her suck his dick.
There's,
I've,
I've had a friend who that was her
thing.
We've all,
everyone Louis C k does a bit about
that.
We've all had women where they're like,
no,
no.
And then you stop and they go,
you find it the next day.
No,
no.
You were supposed to.
Oh yeah.
Louie had the thing like,
I'm not going to take a chance
to find out if it's your thing.
I got an email,
I can talk about this all the time,
but I got an email from a girl that said
thank you for raping me last night.
Oh,
but that might be that like right up to
the girls.
And I always say like that and they
might be joking around.
Oh yes,
of course she was.
But that was her way of saying you got
right to the line.
But I noticed this when I moved to New
York too.
I was,
went to college in the 90s when it was
about permission and feminism.
So I tried that.
I was like,
do you,
is this okay?
Is this feminist?
And let's be clear about that.
You are a feminist at one point your
life,
would you define yourself as a feminist?
I still would.
In many ways.
I see them as magical centi and beings.
They're wizards.
They can make a fucking person come out
of their current
and to say they're dudes is,
is to trivialize.
It's like saying to Clark Kent,
just be a journalist.
Just focus on your journalism and Clark
Kent's a shitty journalist.
You're a shitty man.
Does he have one store that he came in
his story I've ever,
he's turned time backwards.
Oh,
that's right.
But he's never broken a story,
but we keep telling women,
no,
no.
Come to our meetings.
Come to where a tough mudder relay and
walk through electrical wires and go
underneath.
So good at that.
By the way,
you tough mudder people that fucking
water you would never drink.
You would never drink puddle water.
Right?
Right.
Yeah,
of course you wouldn't.
Well,
guess what?
Fuck face you getting that water in your
mouth when you're crawling around.
That same shit that you would get in
your intestinal tract.
You're going to get in your mouth and
you're going to get sick as fuck.
Okay.
So big God damned careful when you're
doing those things.
It seems like a weird beef to have.
Well,
tough mudder or people to the puddles
are way too.
You gotta be really careful about
drinking puddle water.
Like I know guys who have gotten
Giardia,
they've gotten like some serious
intestinal disorders from drinking
water.
Yeah,
well,
you're out in the mountains.
You go out in the mountains and like
they don't bring water with them or
their,
they,
the water filter breaks or they put
these a iodine tablets of the water,
but they don't wait long enough.
Then they drink it and you're getting
these live bacteria in your body and
they wreck havoc with your system.
I mean,
put you out for months.
Okay.
I won't drink puddle water,
please.
So anyway,
you're fucking chicks.
And,
uh,
through trial and error,
there's that time that you're on 24,
and you're fucking girl from behind and
you go,
yeah,
you like that and you go,
I'm going to try a dad thing just,
and then you go,
who's your?
Yeah,
you'd like that daddy's fuck.
And then all of a sudden,
pussy juice galore and she's coming and
you go,
oh,
okay,
I'm going to keep mining this vein.
I'm your father,
blah,
blah.
You start saying shit like that.
And then you start and then you come to
New York and Jewish girls in New York,
they're like,
choke me.
Kill me.
I'm a fucking whore.
Slap me.
And you're like,
um,
like that,
uh,
no harder.
You fucking pussy.
See those,
those,
those girls never made their way to me.
Oh really?
Yeah.
You fucked girls in New York?
No.
Well,
I did,
but I think I,
I don't know,
maybe.
man.
Maybe I just shied away from them or
something like that.
I had some domestic violence in my house
when I was growing up.
Old Shit like that.
I was like,
well,
that's kind of what I'm saying.
We don't naturally go.
There were sweeties I had one girl that
liked to get choked though it,
but it always weirded me out.
We don't,
we're not that enthusiastic about it,
but if they want us to dress like
clowns,
I would put it on the little nose.
Yeah,
it is.
You get into it after a while you
realize it's awesome,
but don't want to get choked by someone
who knows how to choke you though.
You want to get choked by someone
ineffective,
like a sloppy choke where you could
still breathe.
Well,
I remember it was fucking this Jewish
girl and she was,
she said,
kill me.
Whoa cheese.
And uh,
obviously I didn't do that.
And then she's like,
I'm your fucking whore at some coming on
her.
She's like,
I'm your dirty whore.
And then she's having a cigarette after
and she goes,
I brought your whore.
By the way.
I was like,
Duh.
And I thought the Liberals now are
ruining that whole role playing fun game
that we all play.
And sex is a nebulous,
it's like religion,
it's personal,
it's private.
It's a weird area where you do weird
things.
You say stupid shit.
Like I want to lick your cock because
you're thinking,
I want you to suck my cock and want to
lick your pussy,
but you're so horny.
You're brain goes,
yeah,
I want to lick your balls when you look
my balls.
Sorry.
Yeah.
Dirty talk is so awkward.
I can't do fucking stupid.
I just can do like so good.
Love it.
Heaven.
Yeah,
but it's also like when you're intimate
with someone,
it's like you're,
you're sharing that extremely vulnerable
moment.
I mean,
it's,
look,
it's vulnerable nature because you don't
have your clothes on,
you know,
and just,
you feel weird.
You know,
we always have our clothes on so we
don't have our clothes on.
It's just odd,
you know?
And then like funny nude.
Yeah.
You're funny.
You look funny and you're aroused and it
feels good and you're,
you want the other person to feel good.
You feel good to each other and it's
just,
you're looking at each other's eyes and
you're like that close.
It's like,
it's very strange and there's other,
there's also the issue that people
become very addicted to each other.
I think human beings,
especially when having sex with each
other,
it's just like a drug addiction.
I mean,
I remember the first time is in a lot of
ways I think it is.
I think there's a lot of,
there's a lot of endorphins that are
being exchanged and there's a lot of
arousal chemicals that are excluded when
you're with that person that are
extremely potent and when the person's
not there,
there's this deep need to get to that
person.
Again,
just like a drug,
just like,
uh,
you know,
someone who's got hooked on pain pills
and you just,
you have to get the pills.
He got to get the pills.
And I remember,
um,
when I was in,
when I was like 18,
my girlfriend broke up with me and I had
just graduated from high school and I
was really lost and confused.
And when she broke up with me,
I was devastated.
I couldn't believe I had to be without
her.
And it was very much like withdrawal
from a drug.
It was like probably the worst breakup
for me ever because it was the first
one,
you know?
And I was like,
I can't believe this.
Like this is crazy.
And then I just was amazed at like how
potent it was on my system,
you know,
and how it would fuck with my psyche and
my mind.
I felt like a loser.
I felt like if this girl didn't want me,
like I must be a fool,
I must be a failure.
Well that's the,
we've all had that.
And that's where you learn never to be
vulnerable again.
And you learn to be a man sort of,
but you also learn to me,
I,
I've always been fascinated by
psychology and fascinated by the inner
workings of the mind and the tricks the
mind plays on you.
Cause all throughout high school,
from age 15 on,
I was competing in martial arts
tournaments and there were terrifying,
you know?
And so I was always scared and I would
go from,
I mean,
I,
I'd like to say that all y'all was just
bad motherfucker.
I wasn't scared of Shit.
I was scared of fucking everything,
man.
That's why I was good cause I was
terrified and I was always training
super hard and I wouldn't drink it.
I wouldn't do anything.
I wouldn't,
I smoked pot maybe a couple of times
because I was fucking scared of getting
killed.
I was scared of getting my ass kicked.
So when this happened and this girl
broke up with me,
it was so doug,
just devastating to my,
to,
to my confidence.
And I remember thinking like,
God,
why do I feel like such a fucking loser?
And then breaking it down and try to
figure like,
how was I a winner just like a few
months ago and now I'm a loser.
Like in my mind,
I feel like a fucking loser and I can't
get laid.
Girls that smelled desperation.
I mean they run from me like Ah,
like,
like 18 year old girls.
When you're desperate,
they fucking,
they smell,
you stink like a sewer and they run from
you.
My couldn't get laid for like six
months.
I couldn't even get close.
It's nature.
You,
you played yourself,
you were vulnerable.
You learned to never do that again.
And I think adult men,
especially married men,
have to understand that you're
constantly in high school when you're
married.
It's not Dale Aiken when I was eight
years old,
he said,
dude,
when you're married,
you can just go up to your wife and go,
let me see your tits.
Does she has to show you her tits right
there.
And I thought,
I cannot fucking wait.
I remember seeing him,
I'm just going to put my face in her
vagina and just go blow.
Uh,
but you can't do that if I want it to my
wife and said,
show me a tip sheet.
Say Fuck off.
So you're constantly wooing them
according to,
and I had a buddy who got divorced
recently and he said,
I just found myself having to draw lines
in the sand and make these parameters
around how it can be treated and how it
can be spoken to.
And he goes,
I've never had to do that before.
I shouldn't have to do that.
And they go,
dude,
that's what marriage is.
You're constantly on a date.
I was on a date with my wife last night.
Uh,
we got a hotel in the city or my kids
are staying with their grant.
We're,
we're here on vacation in Malibu.
And uh,
I was constantly going,
all right,
I wanted her to have a good night.
She wants to get Tacos,
but also I have to draw the line and
say,
no,
actually we're going here,
we're going to the comedy store,
we're going to meet Don Barris and go
upstairs and blah blah.
So I was giving her some democracy but
also taking the reigns and it's a push
and pull that we've been married,
we've known each other since 2001 but
it's constantly like first day trying to
get in her pants,
watch the real housewives,
pretend to care about that.
Chico was Pinot Grigio all the time
trying to get pussy.
You're not guaranteed the pussy.
No.
If you are,
you have a very strange relationship and
you probably not going to be satisfied
with it because that's part of what's
going on in a relationship is that
wooing is also like kind of that wooing
and courting and,
and,
and being nice to each other.
It's very important to like how the
whole thing works.
Yes.
It's what attracts like we were,
we were in Costa Rica on those stupid
sands of flights that are one engine.
So if it goes out,
we're dying and the turbulence was
insane.
And so she's gripping me and I'm like,
it's okay.
It's just a bus.
We're in a bus in the sky.
I am shitting my pants,
my heart is pounding through my chest
and I'm holding her rationally,
explaining to her what is going on.
And then I'm looking at the window
going,
holy fuck,
we're going to fucking die.
We're going to fucking die.
Holy Shit.
And I still married to her for years.
We've got kids.
I have to convey this man in order to
keep her pussy wet.
And it's the same with sons
particularly,
but kids in general.
But so much of being a dad is being a
prison warden.
And even after bedtime,
you're walking down the hallways to see
if lights are on.
The other day I go into my son's,
my middle son's room,
I touch the light bulb is reading light
and I can feel it's warm.
I'm like,
what's going on in here?
Where you reading?
He was like,
yeah,
a little bit.
Bedtime is bedtime.
Went back with my little fucking,
it was 10 30 at night and he's reading
mad magazine was blackjacks black
[inaudible] thing when I was a kid,
cops had them.
I remember it was like,
it was a leather like paddle with low
shot and yeah,
whack people with it.
So really shitty weapon cause it only
hurts,
you know,
you walk someone out if you hit him on
the jar,
the back of their head.
But if you're covering up and someone's
whacking you with that blackjack,
not so bad.
I'll take a shot with a black jack to
try to get ahold of you.
But like a club,
like a club or a baton,
like that's going to really fucking
hurt.
A blackjack is weird.
It's a weird weapon.
It kind of went away.
They're like,
yeah,
this isn't the best thing to be carrying
around.
I remember wanting to get one of those
aerial sort of in tennis.
Those are dangerous.
Those cops told me I'm not allowed to
have that.
You can have a leather man,
you could buy those.
Yeah,
but you're not allowed to have it on
you.
Leatherman and pepper spray or Anna
maglite flashlight.
You can have,
wait a minute.
So You concealed carry,
meaning walking around,
you're not allowed to have one of those,
but you're allowed to have a knife.
You could have a knife if it's a utility
knife and it's smaller than the palm of
your hand.
I'm talking about New York rules.
Right?
And then at Nyu I was going to do that
talk.
I got pepper sprayed.
Perfectly legal if they can argue that.
No.
Who was pepper sprayed you and did you
see the person doing it and do you know
who they are?
They are all the same.
They're all middleclass,
uh,
kids of professors,
they all live at home.
They all look exactly the same.
They look British.
Uh,
how do they look?
British?
I don't know.
They have like these angular features
and these Roman noses in glasses,
they all look exactly the same.
Nothing Italian about them.
Now what was it that they pepper sprayed
you about?
Will you actually get going to do tacos
and going by the College Republicans?
I started this gang called the proud
boys.
And how boys?
The proud boys.
What is was proud boys about?
We have chapters all over the world.
We meet once a month.
We,
uh,
we uh,
get drunk and just,
it's like the elks lodge like Mason's or
whatever.
Celebrating manhood.
Yeah,
no women allowed.
Oh Wow.
Can't tell your woman what goes on at
the meetings.
Uh,
and we have different degrees like the
knights of Columbus first degree,
you declare yourself a proud boy.
Second degree.
We'd beat the shit out of you until you
can name five breakfast cereals and you
have to give him masturbating.
And then third degree,
you still have to give up masturbating,
but you have to get a tattoo and then
fourth degree you get arrested or in a
serious violent fight for the grills.
Yes.
You get arrested in a serious violent
fights.
So you're promoted by some sort of major
altercation.
You shouldn't erase that part.
Well we don't,
we don't encourage it.
But if you're defending is like at the,
at the Berkeley thing with Milo,
we just,
the my guys just 14 of them just walked
into a mob of 200 people just to get
their stripes.
Said I thought you guys were tough.
No they were doing it just for fun and
these people outside of pepper spray and
clubs,
they can't fight.
Like at the Nyu thing,
my guys were beating them up and he
goes,
this one guy we call friar tuck cause
he's just a monster.
He goes,
I started feeling bad in it.
I started feeling bad after a while
cause I was just,
I could tell these kids had never been
in a fight and I was just mowing through
them.
They're terrible fighters.
They're total proceeds fighting like
this is what confuses me.
Like why are they getting so angry that
they're hitting people and spraying that
girl in the face.
The girl was really disturbing because
she was talking to someone and she
wasn't offering any threat and she,
she had a hat that looked like a make
America great again hat but it said make
bitcoin great again.
They walk up to her,
the guy hits her with a stick that's
holding a sign.
So he hits her in the head with a piece
of wood and she's like,
what the fuck?
And someone sprays her in the face with
pepper spray.
I mean it's like how in any way,
how could you ever,
in any other scenario justify beating a
woman publicly for doing nothing but
representing what you think is offensive
and you're even a wrong about what she's
representing.
Here's the problem with what you're
doing.
And I did this too much to your
intellectualizing a fashion movement.
This is the mods and the rockers in
Brighton Beach in 1961 just fighting
each other because one likes Elvis and
the other likes the WHO.
And if you were to sit down with this
mod in this rocker and say,
have a debate,
they wouldn't say anything.
They have nothing to say.
It's leather versus park cause it's
vespas worth versus triumph motorbikes.
There's no context there.
So this guy is on this team and she's on
the other team and that their tool is
pepper spray and that's what they're
doing.
There's no that's,
they pretend,
oh,
I don't want to give you a platform.
No,
they don't want to give you in anything
because they don't have anything to say.
In fact,
at the Nyu talk I,
after I watched the pepper sprayed,
I went and did the talk.
They're all screaming,
uh,
who's campus?
Our campus.
As soon as I walk over to the mob with a
microphone and I have to and Oh,
come on up,
come on up.
And it was a radioactive cock.
I was handing him like,
he just went,
well because then it was a mike.
He shriveled up because he wanted to be
a part of the big group.
Right.
And didn't want to be an individual with
an opinion and didn't exactly know why
he was there in the first place and
exactly know what he was protesting
against.
That's why like Milo would kill to
debate any of these people.
He's,
he's been scrounging for pneumonia.
The problem is that they're not
debating.
That's the real problem.
I feel like this could be really
productive if people could sit down in
Milo,
by the way,
we'll debate you.
I mean he might say outrageous things.
He might say offensive things,
but he will debate.
He will sit in front of a podium here.
We always time and anyone else will that
will have their time and they will be
able to take questions from the
audience.
And this could be very productive and
you could kind of figure out like what
you and I are not far left and we're not
far right.
You know,
neither one of us are.
We're,
we're in some sort of a weird way.
I think I'm more maybe more left than
you are,
but I'm not as left as a lot of people I
know and there's a lot of people out
there and I think this left white right
paradigm is really kind of fucking
foolish at this point.
And we should kind of figure out like
what's,
what kind of opinions are okay to have
because they don't interfere with
anybody else's life.
And it's just a,
your philosophy and the way you look at
the world and you should be able to
express that opinion and express those
ideas in front of someone else who has
an opposing idea and they tell you why
they disagree and you should be able to
consider why they disagree and see if
there's any merit in that.
The problem you're w with what you're
saying is you're implying that these are
all informed people right and left and
they need to hash out ideas.
No,
these people on the right are
intelligent people who have looked it up
and want to debate.
You want to see a good debate.
Pat Buchanan versus Sean Hannity or
Peter Brimelow versus some open borders
libertarian like uh,
uh,
Matt Walsh or something or someone from
the Wall Street Journal.
All the inner right fights are
fascinating to me.
These people are religious fanatics.
They,
they,
for them it's sports.
It's The Dallas cowboys is their team
and they want to fuck up your team.
They don't want it to be like jared
diamond who did guns,
germs,
and steel.
Tons of flaws with that book.
Steve sailor was begging him for debate.
You wouldn't answer.
Uh,
J uh,
jared Taylor,
John Derby,
Shire,
all these three,
even Richard Spencer,
all these far right guys have made it
clear.
They'd love to argue with anyone on the
other side and the other side knows that
they will lose because their foundation
isn't truth or information.
Their foundation is just emotions.
We're a nation of immigrants,
so everything's racist.
Oh,
gays are people too.
And you like you think,
I don't think gays are fucking people.
What is your point?
I don't even understand your side of
things.
Right.
Well I'm sure you saw that woman,
excuse me,
who's a,
a a middle school teacher who uh,
was a part of the protest at Berkeley.
Yeah.
She was on Carlson Tucker Carlson show
and she was talking about fascism and
she said that Milo is homophobic even
though he's fucking gay.
Yeah,
he's a racist.
Homophobe who sucks black cock.
Yeah.
It's so hilarious.
And she was also saying that he promotes
genocide.
Like you can't just throw those labels
out and that,
that,
I mean it's a clear example of what
we're talking about.
Cause those labels allow her to do
anything necessary to get you out of the
mix.
And that's fascism.
That is fascism,
that's authoritative,
authoritative thinking,
authoritarian thinking in a,
in a way that's eliminating someone else
from expressing themselves because you
have deemed them unworthy of expressing
themselves.
They're off.
This is a racist,
this is a homophobe.
This is someone who promotes genocide.
We will shut them down.
Like that's,
that's nonsense.
And you could see from her talking on
that show that she,
she talks over him.
She doesn't express herself well.
She doesn't have clearly thought out
reasons for why she's saying he does
these things.
She doesn't have quotes and she's
relying on,
she doesn't say why it's so dangerous
that he has these controversial
opinions.
She just says he's a Nazi,
he's a racist,
he's a homophobe.
He promotes genocide.
We're going to shut them down.
But you can't just say that.
You can't just label people cause
someone could do that to you too.
And they will.
They will.
That's the problem.
I forget her name.
Michelle give Ellis [inaudible] her
name.
Is she really in my car
by any means necessary.
But I was game.
I like playing with these people is play
it through.
They do that at AIA.
They go,
you want to be here?
Okay,
have a beer,
then you're gonna have another beer,
then you're going to get coke and
heroin,
blah,
blah.
Play it through.
Right.
And I always say to these people,
play it through.
So he wants genocide.
Trump wants denison.
Okay?
So he wants to kill what blacks and uh,
Mexicans.
So there's a van that drives to this
house in New Orleans and picks up these
black people and then they went,
they go to a gas chamber.
How does this work?
What happens to their property?
Is that divvied up?
Does a state on that now?
Like are you talking about the Cuban
revolution?
The irony is,
by the way,
whenever you start describing their
universe,
you end up describing Venezuela,
Cuba,
socialist countries,
or you end up describing the Middle
East.
Oh,
he's going to want throw gays off
buildings.
He's going to,
uh,
start stoning women to death who are
rape victims.
You have your villains right there,
but you're purposely ignoring him.
And the other thing that's going on
here,
which is still a theory I'm working on,
but there seems to be a disturbing peek
at what a matriarchy would be like.
And I'm seeing a lot of women in these
movements who are sort of vindictive and
cruel and like this woman we were
talking about,
uh,
you know,
you watch these videos and you hear like
fuck them up,
get 'em get 'em these women voices from
behind the crowd and I called him shit
chest
woman from the University of Missouri.
Can I get some muscle over here?
Remember her?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
She wants men to fight on her behalf.
And you know,
iron man has that blue thing in his
chest.
Yeah.
I don't think women are evil.
I like women are like ironman there
magic.
Right?
But by ripping out that blue thing,
you're ripping out the
ability to have children and be mothers
and everything.
And then you put in a piece of shit into
iron man's chest.
That's what feminists and like this
woman are there shit chests
and they're malfunctioning robots and
they're like,
this kill him.
Milo wants genocide killing.
So do you think that they're imitating
what they think are patriarchal
societies?
They're doing their version of it and
that's what they're doing with this.
The whole matriarchal posturing.
Yeah.
It's like Clark Kent,
I want to run an article.
Ah,
I'm writing Christian.
No,
you're not ready it.
And you go clerk,
simmer down,
dude.
You write your article.
I'm doing mine.
No.
And he crunches.
Oh,
there's not a whole lot of matriarchal
societies in the animal world other than
hyenas.
I try it.
There's a few of them.
There's a few where the females are
larger than the males.
A few bugs especially,
but hyenas in particular,
the female Hyena is,
are much larger than the males.
Even at fake dicks really have a pho
penis.
He has this big large tube,
fake Dick that hangs down.
They actually give birth out of it and
they climb on top of the males and they
fucked him.
And the speculation when there's a lot
of speculation as to why the females are
bigger,
but one of them is that they think that
she has to be bigger because Cayenne is
are so goddamn ruthless.
They eat their babies.
Oh,
so the female has to go get the fuck
away from the baby cooked up when she
gets on top of books,
you pieces of Shit.
It's my baby.
I mean,
there's no more,
you know,
no pun intended,
dog eat dog world than a fucking Hyena
world.
You're out there fighting for scraps
with lions.
Yeah.
Well,
I actually have described to Antifa and
these people as hyenas because that
thing I was talking about at Berkeley
where there are guys went in and said,
I thought you guys were like tough or
something,
was his exact quote.
And they're going get him,
get him,
fuck him up.
And then the guys sort of give up
because no one wants to fight them.
They start walking away and then someone
runs up behind him,
knocks him out with a flag pole as
they're screaming these Italian slogans,
by the way,
like,
no fuck.
She's thought [inaudible] oh from the
1920s are having fun.
They knock yet game there.
Larping and then knocked him out.
And then as soon as he's out,
the hyenas come out and then they start
kicking his unconscious body and they
start grabbing their,
really?
Yeah,
it's online.
You can find it.
Oh,
ugly savages.
The scary thing,
man,
you're going to invite right wing people
to,
to do the same thing and you're going to
get some,
some veterans and you're going to get
some fighters and you can do,
and it's,
it's gonna.
It's gonna be horrific man.
It's going to be horrific.
And again,
you start kicking their ass and then
they're going to come back with weapons
and people are going to show up with
guns.
It always leads to someone showing up
with guns maybe.
And if this keeps going and these,
these protests,
especially the things like the Milo
protest,
I mean maybe now that Milo has been
humiliated and it at least temporarily
side tracked or put down for a bit while
he has to rebuild.
Maybe someone can come along and have
reasonable dialog and do some sort of a
campus be I don't like it.
Why is he doing these things on
campuses?
First of all,
I don't think he gets paid for most of
them.
What?
My theory with Milo is a,
I think his eyesight's getting worse.
His glasses are getting thicker and
thicker and he's sorta going,
this is my moment to make an impact.
So he's just like,
you think he's going blind?
I think so.
Yeah.
You just theorizing this.
He's only like 28.
Yeah.
But you look at him,
he's just can't reading glasses.
They're insane.
Really?
Yeah.
And they're getting thicker.
Maybe it's stress,
stress,
stressing his eyes worse.
Um,
I don't know.
I'm not a doctor.
I can't think it would be good.
But I think he's trying to make a
maximum impact in a short amount of time
because you think he doesn't have much
time left.
That's such a way.
He seems healthy.
Totally wrecked eight.
In fact,
when we were in Orlando,
we made out at the site of the,
uh,
you guys made out at the Milo to offend
Muslims.
Wow.
So I said,
what was,
I did a big speech about freedom and
funny states in this America delicious
strawberries.
Well,
at least he freshens breath up before no
gaze just tastes better.
I said,
fuck is lamb.
And then we made out at the site of the
Orlando shooting to the Noi Muslims,
but we had armed guards and stuff.
And I said,
all right,
I want to make sure these guys are
scoping out the rooms and shit.
And he goes,
I don't care if I die,
I'll happily die for this.
I was like,
well,
I do care.
Actually.
I've got three kids.
What does,
is it Neil Ism or nihilism?
I always say it wrong.
I always say nihilism,
nihilism,
that nihilistic sort of instinct that he
has.
He has a burn it all down instinct.
And I think he has that with his life as
well.
And I think a lot of that,
um,
I'm playing some serious bro
psychologists here.
You know,
some armchair psychology from someone
totally unqualified,
but you've got to attribute that to in
at least in some ways being molested as
a child.
I would imagine that his experiences
that he's calling positive experiences
when he was young,
in many ways those could have
potentially damaged him and also being
young and being homosexual and being
rejected.
All of those things wreck havoc and you
develop this,
fuck you,
I want to burn it down.
And this is one of the strategies that
he sort of adopted that strategy to be
this guy who was very difficult for like
he's,
he's gay,
he's an English gay guy who's a right
winger and mean it's,
it's so baffling to them.
They don't know what to do.
They hate it because they see blacks and
gays as their little pets and they like
putting them on the front lines and
going look good who were helping.
And then when one of them defects to the
other side,
they become particularly outraged,
but very few defect at the level that
he's defected.
Right?
I mean,
he turned around and started attacking
direct guy who bankrupted buzzfeed with
the Hulk Hogan lawsuit.
Peter Thiel,
is that his name?
Teal.
Uh,
the silicon valley billionaire.
He's on trump's sort of board,
right,
isn't he?
He's one of the people that trump has
appointed to help him with technology or
something.
I think there's some sort of,
see if he could find with it.
It's Polish it up.
Jamie a,
there's some sort of a,
a,
a position that he has.
I mean,
he's an interesting one cause he's a gay
man and he's a hugely successful
entrepreneur,
billionaire character.
So He's,
he's a weird one too.
Like these guys that get that they're
supposed to,
like,
if you're gay,
you should be on the left.
If you are,
you know,
if you're,
uh,
transgender,
you should be on the left.
Like when Bruce Jenner became Caitlyn
Jenner and steady still against gay
marriage,
everybody was like,
what about fuck?
What in the fuck?
He's a trump supporter and he's against
gay marriage.
But now call me Caitlyn,
and this is my favorite part was when
they asked him like,
uh,
like ellen,
like really sort of grilled him on it
and he goes,
we're all more of a traditionalist or
you definitely aren't you?
Fuck,
well that makes sense to me though.
Cause if you see women as so special
that it's a major thing to go over
there,
then you must have a 1950s view of a
lady that's a Dorothy Day girl with a
poodle skirt doing the vacuuming because
liberals and college students just go.
You and I are chicks,
so they don't see it as a long jump,
but Bruce Jenner sees it as this massive
pole vault.
Can I Peter Thiel?
Yeah,
sure.
Peter Thiel,
Teal ads,
uh,
allies to trump transition.
So it says,
starting to make his mark on trump's
transition team teal,
a billionaire investor and facebook
board member joined the transition team
days after the election and gradually
bringing in other members of his circle.
While teal clashed with Silicone Valley
during the campaign by endorsing trump
early,
this group may be the strongest or only
bridge between the tech industry.
And the president elect,
this is to me,
while Gavin's painting,
this is to me the most volatile time
that I can ever remember.
Like the most vulnerable I've felt like
our country is like as a nation,
like as a structure,
as a traditional structure like
president and vice president,
Congress and Senate.
Now that Gavin's returning,
I was just saying that I think this is
the most vulnerable I've ever felt like
this country is in terms of like its
structure.
Yeah.
I just see it as a soldier divided
cleanup.
I feel great.
Yeah.
Why do you think it's a cleanup and in
what way?
Uh,
trump hiring people as heads of
departments that hate that department.
I hate the government.
I want it reduced to almost nothing.
Right?
So when you have someone in the
Department of Education that likes
charter schools and hates public
schools,
I go get in there.
Just start dismantling the unions,
the teachers' unions.
Start tearing them to shreds,
make it possible to fire a teacher.
Let's get the free market.
And that is a huge,
wonderful,
that is a huge issue.
I have a friend whose daughter is going
to the school and he is absolutely
furious because the teacher has tenure.
You literally can't fire the most.
They commit some sort of a felony and
this woman doesn't give a fuck about her
classes and he was describing like how
negligent she is as a teacher and how
how careless and how little effort she
puts into it because she has the class,
it's hers,
it's like a free paycheck and she's just
not the type of person that's committed
to our work and she can't be fired and
he's so furious and so frustrated with
the public school system and how it all
works at.
He's gonna pull his daughter out and put
her in a private school now.
Yeah,
I had to do that too.
I got to,
I call it the $40,000 posted note.
I've got to post postnatal my daughter's
homework and said,
you're awesome while you are.
No Way.
Yup.
Public schools.
She also got no markers because my
daughter used markers on our homework.
M R K no markers.
This is a teacher.
Yeah.
Wow.
Well,
if you don't have that squiggly red line
underneath your text,
it's very difficult to tell what the
fuck you just said and what's wrong with
it.
Does it,
does this trump thing bother you with
the tax returns?
No,
not at all.
That bothers me a lot.
Really?
Yes.
Cause I want to know how much money he
makes from Russia.
He's got significant business ties with
Russia apparently.
W were you concerned about Hillary's
ties with Russia?
No.
Look,
look,
mom,
I'm know Hillary's porter by any stretch
of the imagination.
I think she's impossibly corrupt.
I think she represents,
um,
this system where people get to a place
of influence and they use that influence
to make massive amounts of money by
giving speeches to bankers and finding
ways to profit and look there.
They're shutting down the Clinton
Foundation,
right?
You're aware of that,
Yeah.
Like this is,
yeah.
I mean,
this,
the whole thing was a big,
as soon as she hasn't had any power
anymore.
Gee,
how weird at this whole thing is
shutting down.
It's a pay to play scheme.
Yep.
And that's really what it's been the
entire time and everyone knows that,
but it's one of those things where the
left didn't want to talk about it
because it weakens our position.
It strengthens the right,
but by not talking about it,
it makes them extremely vulnerable as
well.
So I'm the,
I'm no supporter of anything that she
stand for or bill stands for,
especially now,
but he,
he makes me nervous.
Their skin,
they're spending more money on travel
and he complained how much of Obama
spent on travel.
The trump will have spent more money on
travel in the first seven months than
Obama did in the entire eight years was
in the White House because he's flying
back and forth tomorrow,
Lago,
back and forth to Manhattan.
He's doing whatever the fuck he wants to
find his kids when his kids have to fly
to do business forum,
when they're opening up casinos,
it's all secret service.
Everything is being done with taxpayer
money.
It's,
he is the most very consistently
threatened president in history.
I mean that the Daily Mail printed this,
no,
sorry.
The Daily News in New York printed this
list of how many people would have to be
killed to get to a Democrat and they go,
we're just throwing this out there just
so you can see.
We'd have to be this person and then
there's the vice president and the
secretary,
then the postmaster general blah blah,
blah,
and you go,
why are you publishing hit lists?
Why would they do that?
Because the pizzas come in.
I've seen it all over the place.
People will read it.
Comedians are talking about it too,
like let's just take them out and you
just got to be taken out.
Comedians are saying more said something
strange could happen before some crazy
horror said.
Something like that too.
Well that was Sarah Silverman too.
She had this thing she was,
she was advocating,
she was saying that once the military
steps in the mad king will no longer be
there.
Like what?
You do not want the fucking military to
run the country ever.
Do you understand what that means?
If they can kill the president,
that can kill you too.
Do you?
You have to be absolutely out of your
fucking mind to want the military to
step in and run the country.
You are advocating a military
dictatorship because by the way,
that's what happens in the military
comes over when they take over.
You don't get a vote.
There's no fucking vote now that's all
gone.
The people with the guns are now running
things and they do whatever the fuck
they want and it's very inconvenient for
them to have to sit down and listen to
people who go to Largo on Tuesday night
to watch Sarah Silverman speak like it's
very inconvenient for them to take your
opinion into consideration and they're
not going to,
well,
the implication there too is that she's
running it like General Brigadier Judd
Apatow is calling up the commands of
God.
General Patton Oswald just don't think
they found the tanks.
They haven't thought it through.
They never think it through because it's
just religion.
It's all platitudes.
It's all mods and rockers made up.
Shit.
What's also,
there's a lot of posturing online when
you're making these statements online.
You're doing it to not just because you
have something to say,
which I believe there's something there,
but also because you want love.
You want people to,
to like what you're saying,
you want people to retweet it.
You want people to say,
hey,
that guy is really on the ball.
That girl is really on top of politics.
Yeah,
you go girl.
You know you're saying the right things.
Yeah,
fuck him.
We've got to get up.
But they're,
they're not,
they're not thinking this thing out.
You had a contest.
There's a fucking contest.
The person that you had go against the
person that you were,
you didn't want to win sucked.
So the person who won won the fucking
contest.
You can't just come in and say,
now the military has to take over
because I don't agree with the results
of the contest.
We have a country,
the country is filled with 350 million
people,
uh,
enough with your shitty electoral
college system decided that this guy
should win the contest.
He Won.
He won fucking fair and square.
Whether or not the Russians were
involved in hacking the DNC.
Take that aside,
look at it for what it is,
because what the Russians exposed was
fucking corruption.
And I don't,
they are obsessed with these emails and
I go,
you know,
that's not what lost it for her.
There was no real smoking guns and those
emails there was,
what's her name,
uh,
donate,
to come up with questions for CNN.
There was jake tapper looking dirty and
there,
there was a jake tapper looked dirty
from,
uh,
he looked like he was getting questions,
talking points from the DNC.
There was shit up.
Yeah.
There was,
um,
there was also the,
the very clear collusion where they were
making that Bernie Sanders did not win
the primaries.
Right.
That was where it was most disturbing to
me because it's that leap through
emails.
Yes,
yes.
Yeah.
I mean,
she did something corrupt.
Yeah.
She,
it's not the crops and they're saying,
well,
the Republicans didn't,
didn't get exposed and well,
the implication is that the Russians had
something on them,
but there was a deal.
But how do you know that's the case?
They might not have done anything
illegal.
That's also possible.
It's possible.
It's possible that if you look at the
very minimal amount of things that were
done by the DNC,
there's just a few incidents.
None of them landed anybody in jail.
Right.
So I think we can kind of agree that
whether or not they are corrupt,
they're fairly minimal,
even though you are fucking with
democracy.
I mean that's what you're doing when
you're rigging the primers.
You're fucking with democracy.
No one went to jail.
So the worst case scenario that they
were a tribute that was attributed to
them was still not enough to warrant a
criminal investigation or jail time.
Then you have the other side and you're
supposed to assume that their side was
more egregious or was it equal and we're
just not exposed.
Like what?
Look,
all the shit that was exposed.
Look at all,
look at that Billy Bush interview you're
telling me that sounded worse than
anything that was exposed on the other
side as far as like public opinion,
it seemed to resonate more.
I don't know why it was just a dumb
joke,
but it seemed to be,
that's what that march was.
It was a pussy joke.
March.
Look,
trump won because of transgender
bathrooms.
He won because of the grievement
industry.
He won because of the liberal media
spinning stories.
He won because we're all sick of
governor obamacare.
Obamacare was a lot of factors.
There was so much animosity built up
against the establishment that when
Rodney dangerfield showed up in,
in Tartan Pants,
and today you whoa,
Whoa,
whoa,
someone stepped on a duck.
We all went,
that fucking guy.
I want him to come in and just blow it
all up and let's start from scratch.
It doesn't leak.
But the,
but the ties to the Russians,
that doesn't bother you at all?
No.
The fact that he won't release his
taxes,
it doesn't bother you at all?
No,
that bothers me because we should know
where money comes from.
But look at what they do.
Look at this obsession with reframing.
Things like Milo's sentence,
uh,
has been construed to mean he wants 13
year olds to have sex all the time with
adults.
Uh,
every time they get a,
like w ann coulter said,
our blacks are better than their blacks.
She meant conservative.
Blacks tend to be more well researched
cause they get a hammering at
Thanksgiving from their family and
they're not conforming to the majority
of their race.
So they tend to be heartened that gets
construed into ankles or thinks we still
have slaves and blacks.
So you can just see the way these tax
returns,
especially in an era where we seem to
hate entrepreneurs and we seem to hate
wealth.
And me,
I've heard so many people criticized
trump saying he's a billionaire or the
betsy devoss cause she's a billionaire
and you go since when is that a fucking
insult?
That's the only thing everyone on earth
wants to be.
Well,
okay.
I mean you're kind of setting up a bit
of a straw man with that because I don't
think that's just what people are
challenging and what people are upset
about with trump with they're about is
that they believe that he might be
influenced by foreign governments that
have a vested interest in controlling
our democracy.
And that's what the Russian thing is
scary.
If he's making considerable amount of
money in Russia and a considerable
amount of money in China,
you have to wonder whether or not he
will be influenced by that financial
tie,
by those financial ties and whether or
not that that will influence way the
policy that it creates in this country.
Whether or not he allows things to
happen that we don't think should
happen,
just so that he can profit valid
concern,
but it's not proven yet.
And if it is proven,
we'll drag him out of the White House by
his heels.
But don't you think that the only way
you're ever going to really prove that
is by seeing his taxes?
You have to,
you have to see his tax returns and how
business works.
We,
that's why I bring up this Auntie Auntie
entrepreneurial age.
Like with the bankruptcy laws in the
nineties everyone was taking advantage
of bankruptcy laws because the
government was so bad at its job.
So they,
uh,
trump had to go on at the same with his
manufacturing,
his ties in China.
I've tried to make things in America
like toy dolls it,
they were going to be 17 times the price
if we didn't make them in China.
So it wasn't like it would be a
challenge.
It just wasn't possible.
Once that system is like that,
you have to adhere to that system if
you're going to eventually change it.
And I think people are going to see
these tax returns,
they don't know what the fuck they're
doing and they're going to go,
oh,
here's proof that he's in bed with these
people.
But well,
some people are going to be able to
analyze them and come up with accurate
assessments of where,
where he's being influenced and where he
makes money and why that can be a
problem and why could be a conflict of
interest.
But we should be able to have that
information.
Every single president before him has
been forthcoming with that information.
He,
yeah,
every day was going to release a
financial loser maybe,
but he said he was going to release it
up until the moment where he got in and
then he said,
no,
why should I?
I guess I dunno.
It's,
you don't think they should force him to
release the tax returns?
She to me,
like these,
these people,
they,
they're,
they're worried about foreign influence.
We had Hillary,
uh,
showing us her foreign influence,
rainy,
and we showed her selling the
presidency,
having Bill Clinton do a talk about this
doesn't exonerate trump,
right?
No,
but where were you then?
You pronounce it of you,
right?
You're right.
We're not talking to them.
Right.
We talking to me and I'm,
I'm not a left wing hillary supporter
and in any way,
shape or form.
I just think that if we're going to have
a president,
we have to have some pretty universal
rules that we follow.
And one of them should be,
the president should be beyond
influenced by foreign governments.
And there's really,
there's really not a whole lot of ways
to tell what's influencing you other
than tax returns.
So you,
you're implying that in these tax
returns,
you're going to see massive checks from
rush.
I'm not saying that.
I'm saying we should find out.
I mean,
you should.
Absolutely.
You're,
you're the president.
You shouldn't,
it's,
it's very eroding.
It erodes the public confidence.
If you hide that,
if you conceal that,
if you don't tell us where you have your
money stored,
you don't tell us where you're,
where you're making money,
where you have bank accounts,
where you,
where you know there's,
there's a lot of factors involved in a
guy like trump was running a massive
global empire and if,
if we don't know like where he's being
influenced through his financial
connections,
I feel it,
I feel like that's really problematic
and I think it's,
it's,
it's a real dangerous thing to deny it
because it's always been,
it's always her spin,
what presidents do and we've always said
it was a good thing and I always thought
it was law.
I thought it was mandatory.
I never knew that there was a way to get
around under a,
they're under the being an under audit
right now that was over.
He says it's still going and it's been
going since the 70s or something like
that or that atl area.
So he just has to keep the audit going
then it doesn't have to tell us how
much.
Yes.
I mean,
I understand your logic.
I just,
the bigger picture here is I think that
people don't understand that he took a
major hit and uh,
becoming president financially.
And I think that was part of the appeal.
Americans went,
Holy Shit,
you're putting it all on the line for
us.
But he's not losing tons of my sons are
running the business and they're doing a
great job doing it took a huge hit and
none,
oh yeah.
How so is residences the golf courses?
Well,
that Mara Lago,
the attendance is up and they raise the,
uh,
admission fee to $200,000 a year.
That's how much it costs now to join
there.
My understanding is the brand with his
residencies and his golf clubs and
everything else took a major hit.
And I understand that because it's like
if you're in New York and you say,
we're up mets,
mattress company,
well it doesn't,
it's not that people are anti med,
but now Yankees fans don't want your
mattress.
So Z,
anything political when you're a brand
like that is going to lose you 50% of
your followers.
And he went on a limb and if you'd lost
the election,
he still would have had that brand
damage without any of the benefits and
what he saw and put everything on black
and they went,
I appreciate you risking that.
Has that been proven that his brand has
been damaged?
Like if there's been any studies of like
attendance or a residency's dropping
that shit up.
It wasn't the people that owned condos
in one of the trump buildings tried to
change the name in New York.
They literally ripped the word trump off
of their building.
They did do that,
right?
Yep.
Yeah,
they had construction and these are
people that own condos in that building.
Right.
So it's a,
it's a place where you buy the New York.
So weird like that.
You buy your apartment.
It's so strange.
But they pulled the trump name down.
Oh,
whose,
whose idea is that and how do we get
away board all agreed it was a
democratic decision and they said,
we don't want to sell.
They probably don't want to be targeted
to,
because I was there right after the
election.
I just happened to be there because of
the UFC was there and Madison Square
Garden right after the election.
So I walked to the gym and when I came
back it was like,
why we're in the gym,
the the riots or the parade?
The march started and so we walked back
right in the thick of it and they were
parked out in front of the trump tower,
just fucking scream and a bunch of
fucking losers.
I saw the project,
k,
racist,
sexist,
anti gay.
His guy just kept screaming that.
Where did that even come from?
They,
they did another thing where they,
they,
first of all,
they dance up freedom outside of Mike
Pence,
his house.
He's not even there.
Like he gives a fuck.
He never said gaze can't dance.
And then they just do that in New York.
They start making out with each other in
front of the trump building.
Like he's going to go,
oh,
stop it.
Stop it army.
Oh,
I can't see Gargamel from the smurfs.
I hade that.
Well,
it's the same thing we were talking
about earlier with labeling Milo a Nazi
and a fascist and homophobic and
promoting genocide.
If you just say those words and defined
someone,
you immediately put them in a nice box
that you can attack.
Right?
And so by someone you,
this guy was right next to me fucking
screaming it.
Donald Trump KKK,
racist,
sexist anti day.
This was hilarious.
He saw a black guy come in,
he starts yelling,
black lives matter,
black lives matter.
I was like,
oh you son of a bitch.
You fuck.
They come up with this concept that the
president is pro hate.
So then they go,
hey trump,
I'm against hate.
And he goes,
that's nice.
So they build a straw man and then
they're attacking him and letting him on
fire and the rest of us are going,
I don't care that your lighting is scare
crow on fire.
You look fucking ridiculous.
Well it's,
it's not empowering their cause to be
exaggerating about his stances on things
like gay rights or any of these other
things.
It's not empowering.
So when you say he's KKK,
when you say he's anti gay,
when you say he's racist without like
real proof,
like you could say that he has said some
very racist things about some Mexicans.
You can say that.
No you can't.
Well,
you could say that you just talking
about all the rapists and murderers that
are coming over from Mexico who crossed
the border,
the women get raped.
They're at the point now where these
women just take contraception.
Uh,
as part of the deal,
it,
it's almost like it's not rape at this
point because it's a currency.
Let's see.
You're talking to people that are coming
across was saying they're sending
they're rapists.
Okay.
Uh,
and they are a Mexico as an program
where they send their criminals over the
board that he did a good job of
expressing that if that's what people
really want to say.
And I think he could have been more
measured and he could have done it in a
way that would,
but that's not how he talks.
He could've done it in a way that would
have removed any doubt as to what his
intentions are.
How he feels about people,
right?
But it is chest like sometimes he talks
like an idiot,
they're doing bad things and then
okay
you realize four days later,
Holy Shit,
that was brilliant.
So with the Mexicans thing,
these Mexicans are rapists.
You go what?
And then you look it up and go,
Holy Shit,
80% of these women get raped crossing
the border by these coyotes.
Holy Crap.
And then another example of this,
him being four steps ahead,
is when he says he's trying to do this
travel ban,
right?
Muslims are a threat to America.
And everyone goes,
that's crazy.
And then he says,
the press isn't reporting on the
following terrorism cases,
this,
this.
He lists about 20 so then the meeting he
goes,
that's not true.
We reported on this,
we were putting on that,
we put it on the London bombing,
we on Bengazi,
we reported on this.
And then he dupe them into talking about
terrorism for three days straight.
All of a sudden his travel ban looks
pretty reasonable.
Ah,
that's interesting.
So he's off.
He's often setting a trap for people
that they come bounding into.
Well,
whether or not he's doing it on purpose
or whether or not,
just by finding things that he can say
that backup his point,
he's starting that conversation off in a
way that they wouldn't ordinarily start
off.
It might have been what happened with
Sweden,
where he goes,
look what happened with Sweden last
night on a particularly dead night in
Sweden.
Now you could say,
look how many blacks died in gang
warfare today in Chicago.
It might be none today,
right?
But the average is years to write.
And when you look it up and you go,
Holy Shit,
780 people died in Chicago this year.
W is today the 22nd there was a
significant event on the 21st in Sweden.
Massive laughs.
Yeah,
yeah.
Look,
it's Sweden has got problems.
Europe has problems there.
They definitely do.
And whenever you have people from one
culture that immigrate into another
culture and they're disenfranchised and
poor and they have a really not,
so I'm just going to keep going with it.
But,
and they also have a really restrictive
fucked up culture that they're coming
from and they want to impose that
culture on the people that live in
Germany or wherever and they want women
to start wearing long dresses and they
treat them like they're whores.
If they don't,
that's all fucking real dangerous.
They're from a different part of the
world and it's a part of the world that
hasn't changed much in a long time.
And that part of the world,
I mean you could call it culture,
you can call it religious tradition,
but whenever you're dealing with a part
of the world that still has honor
killings and female genital mutilation
and you don't let women drive and you
know you,
you women aren't allowed to vote and you
have this incredibly restrictive world
that you are,
your existing him and then you bring
that world somewhere else,
you're going to have a culture clash.
And you're seeing that.
And this is,
this is,
you know,
if you want people to be free and you
want people to have the ability to
integrate into a more free culture like
America is,
you also have to be honest about what
the consequences are and you have to be
honest about what kind of culture
they're coming from.
And as soon as you talk about that,
you get labeled in Islamophobia.
Soon as you talk about this incredibly
restrictive,
misogynistic culture that's based on an
ancient,
ancient series of rituals and beliefs.
Do you become a racist and a bigot by
talking about a reality like when
they're not a race?
You're talking about culture and I,
it's important to make that distinction
as a Western chauvinist that I think the
West is the best.
I don't care what race you are,
but I don't think that other cultures
are different.
I think they're worse and Islam is 500
years behind us.
We were shitty.
We had witch hunts inquisition,
we had the inquisition.
They're doing,
they're not caught up to us yet.
They're not as advanced.
And I think two big problems with them
as far as progress,
progress goes is the Koran is an
exceptionally violent book.
It doesn't have a 2.0 the way Christians
do and no one ever talks about this.
But they have a major problem with
inbreeding.
They
are marrying their first cousins again
and again and again.
And that makes your evolution group
works.
Is this true?
Where are you getting that from?
I never ever heard of ginnaty.
I think it's called Muhammad said it's
okay to marry your first cousin for real
and you do that once or twice.
It's pretty bad and you do it for 40
generations and now you're going back in
time and look at Iran in 1965 mini
skirts,
woman doing chemistry with test tubes,
driving around.
Hi,
you want to go to the Gogo hot later and
now just garbage bags.
Oh,
Gregorian chants everywhere.
They've gone backwards in time.
And I blame obviously the,
the courage and the culture and
religion,
but also I think inbreeding enables them
to get hijacked by these radicals.
I mean we've got,
you think they can beat snakebites in
America?
Can you mentioned them taking over
Christianity?
Do you think,
well,
there are people in America,
right,
that the do do that still.
It's hilarious.
But they're not taking over America.
The way they took over of the Middle
East you think is the same.
They're the equivalent as far as their,
yeah,
I think Irshad Manji and uh,
uh,
the trouble with Islam,
she says a weird group of Wasabi is just
hijack their religion and sent it into
the dark ages.
And I go,
yeah,
but how were they vulnerable to
hijacking Christianity?
Couldn't be hijacked by the snake guys.
So why,
and I think a part of it was inbreeding.
Uh,
this is our own theory.
No,
no,
no.
Look at them and breeding major,
major problem.
Never heard this,
but especially with immigrants in
Britain,
like the Pakistanis in London,
they'll have all kinds of serious
inbreeding problems because that's an
even smaller sample size you're dealing
with.
Ha.
And every time I bring this up,
people go,
Yo,
what about white people hillbillies?
They were in breeding or royalty.
They were in breeding.
And I go,
yeah.
And it went real bad.
It was a bad move.
Learned the hard way we saw it.
Deliverance.
Well,
there was the first,
I've heard of it,
but pull it up.
I'm,
I'm sure.
I'm sure you're not lying.
You find anything?
Something on snopes popped up.
So,
oh,
snopes,
snopes.
Snopes is,
I've,
once I found out about the origins of
snopes and who's running snopes,
the guy who married a prostitute and
left his wife and didn't know the whole
deal that guys partying.
He married some woman who was an escort.
You ever seen the story on snopes?
Yeah.
The guy who ran snopes ran it with his
wife,
left his wife for a prostitute.
She's still in him because all the money
he spent on prostitutes.
And uh,
now he married the prostitute and she's
not a prostitute anymore.
Now she works for snopes and uh,
oh wow.
I knew it was a husband and wife team.
I didn't know that's how they met.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Now.
Well the,
there was a husband and wife team and
now it's a husband with the new wife.
And then there are suing each other,
the ex wife and the husband or suing
each other over who gets the money.
Some big crazy story,
but he's just got a big fucking smile on
his face and he's hanging out with this
girl.
He used to be an escort and I find that
distasteful unless it's Richard Gere and
Julia Roberts.
Cause they're gorgeous.
And I like it.
Well,
I think it's the best looking guy.
But the prostitute at one point in time,
the Gow who,
uh,
worked as an escort,
I should say,
I don't want to be disrespectful.
I dated an escort ones.
Did you Holla while she was escorting?
No.
Post Post.
She was molested as a kid.
Ooh.
So she,
for sex for her,
we had to go super intense,
like public humiliation.
She wanted me to slap her in a grocery
store and stuff.
Oh Jesus.
Because intimacy had been ruined by dad.
Oh.
So that we had to leap over that and get
right into mean stuff.
Fuck man.
Yeah,
it wasn't great.
But that brings me back to what you were
saying earlier.
Let's just spitball here.
Okay.
Molestation gaze.
Here's my theory.
First of all,
I think 1% of people are gay and 1% 1%
in theory,
like you were thinking 10 all the time.
And it's crazy.
It's fucking nuts.
Told people that's not.
So remember your classrooms,
you'd have three classes.
There was that one fe guy who wore
lacrosse a few costs.
There's a few,
I mean it might be as high as five,
but it's definitely,
I mean,
unless you're in some place with maybe
some sort of a gas leak,
well that's what we're getting at nature
and nurture.
So out.
So there's,
these are gays,
these are lesbians.
I think a higher proportion of lesbians
are that way for getting from getting
molested.
And it's easier to go with a woman cause
they're not as gross as Cox.
So I'm in a more nurturing and they're
also been sexualized by our culture.
Right?
I mean,
they're constantly on billboards selling
things and the right,
you know,
and it's girls kissing girls is hot,
you can just get a strap on there.
I can have a dude and I want to think of
dad.
I'm just totally spit balling here,
making it up.
I'm going to say a third of lesbians
were molested.
Right.
That's a lot.
I'm going to lie within the percentage
of gays.
Less than that.
I'm gonna say a fifth,
a fifth.
This is talking out of my ass here.
A fifth of gay.
So it's possible that Milo was that way.
Lena Dunham,
sister Lena brags about molesting her
sister.
She's a lesbian now she has.
Yup.
Jesus.
So maybe you get molested.
It could be by anyone.
And Sex,
you know,
brings you bad feeling thing.
When children experience sex,
when they're not sexual,
like when they're not,
their hormones have been kicked in.
They haven't reached puberty and they
experienced sex at a very early age.
They become hypersexualized.
And they say that that's one of the
things that happens to women that are
molested.
And they speculate that that could also
be one of the things that happened to
men when they experience a molestation
by another man at an early age.
And there's an imprinting that happens,
Christopher Ryan,
where the author of a sex at dawn has
talked about this,
but there's imprinting that happens
during the formative years and I forget
what those years are.
I think he said between 10 and 14.
But things that can happen during those
years are they like,
they like a lock in and that's where
people develop fetishes and they develop
all sorts of weird sort of like kinky
sort of things that they connect to sex.
And it's because of the fact that your
body and mind are developing your
hormones kicking in.
Yeah.
Makes Sense.
Well,
it's uh,
it's,
it's a disturbing trait and your job as
a parent and as a society is to keep
kids as pure for as long as possible.
You want Santa to go as long as humanly
possible.
He wanted the Easter bunny.
The,
I don't,
I even nine 11.
My kids don't know what nine 11 is.
I'm keeping that race to racism.
They,
I just want them to know that that guy
has dark skin.
I don't want them to know any of those
other things.
And we're living in a culture where
we're normalizing so much decadence that
we're destroying our own innocence in
the process.
Strap yourself in for this 70% of all
Pakistanis are inbred and in Turkey the
amount is between 25 to 30% more
stillbirths among immigrants.
A rough estimate reveals that close to
half of everybody living in the Arab
world is inbred.
A large percentage of the parents that
this is blowing my mind.
Large percentage of the parents that are
blood.
Where's this coming from?
What does this website,
I blog posted it before I came here.
He gave media,
but these are all the sources that went
to this is a,
this sources reproductive health
journal.com.
Uh,
this is a BBC investigation that went to
it.
So,
so listen to the BBC investigation in
Britain several years ago revealed that
at least 55% of the Pakistani community
in Britain was married to a first
cousin.
The Times of India from that in quotes,
this is thought to be linked to
probability to the probability that a
British Pakistani family,
British Pakistani family is at least 13
times more likely than the general
population to have children with the
recessive genetic disorders.
Holy Shit.
Bbcs research also discovered that while
British Pakistanis account for just
3.44% of all births in Britain,
they accounted for 30% of all British
children with recessive disorders and a
higher rate of infant mortality.
What in the fuck Labour Party MP has
called for a ban on first cousin
marriage.
Medical evidence shows that one of the
negative consequences of inbreeding is a
100% increase in the risk of stillbirth.
One study comparing the Norwegians and
Pakistan showed that the risk of child
of the child dying during Labor
increases by 50%.
Wow.
That is insane.
I also read somewhere that's a lot of
the symptoms of inbred people are
irrational rage fanaticism and they end
up just describing isis.
Look at what it says here that um,
with the,
uh,
the Iq points,
it says findings.
Unintelligence research shows that if
one parents are cousins,
if one's parents or cousins,
intelligence goes down 10 to 16 Iq
points.
The risk of having an Iq lower than 70
criterion for being retarded.
In quotes,
they using that word,
who uses that word?
They use it like that.
I'm noticing that you use like I've
always done it.
I don't think it's a medical
distinction.
This is a real website.
The fuck can we read it from?
Did they say no?
It says retarded.
Retarded in quotes.
He had a suit.
Their legal,
that is the medical definition increases
400% among children from cousin
marriages.
Well,
let me say that again.
The risk of having an Iq lower than 70
increases 400% amongst children from
cousin marriages.
An academic paper published in the
Indian National Science Academy found
that the onset of various social
profiles like visual fixation,
social smile and sound seizures,
oral expression in hand grasping are
significantly delayed among the newborn
inbred babies.
What in the fuck could name for a band
newborn inbred babies?
Yeah,
that's our punk or band.
I ever heard one.
Wow.
Jesus Christ.
Then why don't we know this because I've
never don't like the truth.
Islamophobia.
They don't like being called
Islamophobia,
but even discussing it like we're going
to be called Islamophobic for even
bringing this.
I know and I'm glad you read that from a
reputable site,
so it's not a Joe Rogan and Gavin
McInnes is called Muslims retarded.
This is PJ media.
I don't know what that is,
but let's find out if there's other
corroborating or dissenting sources.
Like Pajama media is a,
a a well established network of
champions or what you wear when you want
to be serious about problems with Islam.
If you wear your footie pajamas and he
gets out of the basics,
people are scared of genetics too,
cause it gets into eugenics and they,
they get uncomfortable,
but it gets into racism too.
I come from a Shitty Glaswegian family
and my uncles were drunks and maybe
coming from a shitty group,
you,
you develop this immunity to fear of
your group sucking like,
I don't care what you say about roofs.
I'm battalion mostly Italian.
I'm one quarter Irish and fucking I came
from a line of savages.
They're there.
Eight people,
you know,
it was a good percentage of my ancestors
and relatives that I know that are
fucking ape people and I can say that
cause I know them and I come from them
and I have eight people instincts that I
fight off every goddamn day or my life.
Man,
the first time I came here you were
trying to separate your spinal cord
cause you had crushed it from choking
people out.
While I'm not trying to separate it,
I'm trying to relax it and uh,
decompress it.
Some sound like doctor Zay us right now,
but I've worked,
I did,
I worked at,
it's great.
Now my back works wonderful.
I stretched out.
My philosophy is I don't care what the
truth is,
no such thing as hate fax to me.
Let's hear it.
And I was talking to the facts and they
might be uncomfortable for you,
but they are facts,
the truth and it's best for everyone.
Let's talk about this.
A surgeon recently and I,
he's,
he's trying to accrue a DNA database
that would just sort of like going into
the singularity,
it would be like becoming God and you
would be able to tell from a baby if a
baby is going to have a propensity for
lung cancer and you know right out of
the gate and he,
he's scared of this concept
because he's worried it will affect
insurance policies.
They'll demand to see ya a smear some of
your spit and they'll go,
oh fuck this.
We're not insuring you.
You,
you have a 40% chance of prostate cancer
and 50% chance of this,
the point of insurance.
Cause then insurance gets real weird.
It's not a gamble anymore.
It's like you could see the car.
It's like,
let me see your cards.
No,
I'm not gambling.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
You know,
now it's just a bank account.
Isn't that kind of what insurance is,
right?
It's like I look at you,
Hey Gavin,
let me take your blood pressure.
Well,
uh,
yeah,
a cough.
Okay,
let me hit your knee with this little
rubber mallet.
Everything seems okay.
Hey,
how are you sleeping?
Sleeping pretty good.
Wow.
Okay.
I'm going to give you a positive checkup
and you bring it to the insurance
company and go,
look,
everything checks out.
You're going to insure me.
They're like,
hmm.
All right,
we'll take a chance.
But it is taking a chance.
But do you smoke?
Oh,
you smoke.
I don't like my odds there.
Do Drink.
I don't like my odds.
Well,
as we're getting smarter,
we're turning into those,
those chicks in the hot tub,
in minority report,
and sooner be able to just go,
I can't and chill.
You,
you're dying on the way home today.
Oh No.
I say to him,
I go,
fine.
Let's get it out there.
The free market will figure out
insurance for the doomed,
uh,
some sort of catastrophic policy,
but there'll be more money over here to
even it out.
Information has to come out.
We need this information.
But inbreeding,
I think it explains the hijacking of,
of Muslim religion.
You know,
Hasidic Jews have the same problem,
but they,
because they're aware of this and the
truth is out.
They have all kinds of elaborate DNA
tests.
They do on each other.
Not everyone takes it,
but,
but rabbis will encourage this for us to
check you out and make sure you're not
related and encourage this marriage
because it makes the most genetic sense.
I had no idea you,
you blew my mind with that information.
I'm,
I'm hoping that Jamie's going to pull up
something that shows that that's a right
wing hate group that's infiltrated this
statistics and there does seem to come
on a lot of right wing websites.
I'm trying to find more sources,
but trying to find another source.
So just try to find another source and
we'll continue to talk about other
genetic things.
Have you,
are you aware of Crispr?
You know,
that's some crazy shit and they've,
they've been given the green light to go
ahead and start working on human
fetuses.
I actually had this crazy theory in
church the other day where I thought,
is it possible that we're in heaven?
Like,
you know how the concept of Heaven is
unfathomable,
right?
It's something that's totally different
from where we are now and it's this
infinite universe thing that our brains
can't handle.
And then I was thinking,
wait a minute,
this sounds like a sperm trying to
figure out what earth is,
right?
Maybe the sperm was us being born was
dying.
Now we're alive here on heaven and we're
slowly getting closer and closer to
perfection.
I mean lifespan has been getting better.
The quality of life has been getting
better.
We're going to die soon,
but in like 50 generations with crispers
and all this incredible genetic
information,
soon we might be able to just be like,
we all is.
Usually we have cured your liver
cancers.
Well it's going to get really weird
because they're kind of be able
to integrate the,
the human beings that are here today
with not just communication,
not just visual information,
but some sort of computer language.
Jamie and I were just talking about this
yesterday where we were talking about
emojis and you know,
and this is something that has been
brought up before.
The emojis are in many ways a lot like
hieroglyphs and that they,
you can say something with emojis that
it can kind of translate what you're
thinking without an actual language.
And we're saying we're going to get down
to,
the only words you say are like yes and
no.
Like yeah.
And know like nods and affirmations and
confirmations and the,
the language that we speak could be some
sort of a weird universal emoji based
language that's just expressed from mind
to mind through some neural implants or
some fucking snapchat glasses.
We were,
I mean,
we're not too far away from something
really bizarre and paradigm shifting
like that.
I remember when downloading your brain
was just science fiction movies and you
know,
you talk to people our age about their
dead grandfather and they go,
I have this black and my photo and I
have this letter.
He wrote the newspaper in 1896 that's
all I got my life.
My kids will never be able to read all
the articles I've written or watch all
the videos I've done.
They'll,
they'll never get through them all.
They can watch them for 100 hours if
they're bored.
But they'll,
there's way more of my brain permanently
out there in the cosmos than they could
ever want.
Oh yeah,
for sure is and everything.
So the next generation,
your dad isn't really going to die and
just hang out with them whenever you
want.
Well,
I'm sure you're aware of Ray Kurzwell
and you know Kurzweil's thing is that he
wants to somehow or another recreate his
father cause his father died when he was
young and he has some information about
his father and he has some DNA that
obviously is his and he has,
you know,
photographs and memories and he wants to
figure out a way to literally recreate
his father and have a conversation with
them that I know you,
I know you're an atheist,
right?
No.
Oh I am a nothing.
This is,
I feel like,
you know,
the beginning of atheists where he
drinks that thing and then he
deteriorates and goes into the water.
That's what I think the big bang was.
It was this beautiful microchip that
just started the first domino and
everything else.
He's going to this place like the
singularity is near this incredible
perfection that we're headed to.
And there's all these checks and
balances along the way.
Like I was reading about Audrey Hepburn
the other day and she,
um,
was super skinny,
right breakfast at tiffany's chick.
She grew up in I think,
uh,
the,
Holland during the war and the Nazis
Cutoff Holland from all supplies.
So they were forced to eat lips and
they,
a lot of them,
hundreds of thousands of them starve to
death.
And Audrey Hepburn was from that world
and she was a skinny chick who didn't
need a lot of food.
And then all of her ancestors kids
became obese,
big giant fat pigs.
And they say it could have been genetic
memory where they,
their bodies went,
Holy Shit,
you found Doritos.
I'm going to hold onto this cause you're
never gonna find one again.
And then you get an a,
and I'm noticing this in La with all
these Mexicans I see everywhere,
they seem more obese than the general
populace.
And I think they have genetic memory
from a generation or two ago where food
was scarce and they,
their bodies hold onto it more
thoroughly.
We see this with the American Indians
all the time.
It's a major diabetes problems send its
genetic memory where these are the
checks and balances your,
you're at the fact that a cell can
remember this generation is like you
ever heard cell memory where the you get
an eye transplant and all of a sudden
you're seeing the guy that killed that
guy.
I've heard stories and out but I don't
know if it's ever been proven and it's
still in the got to look it up to prefer
my brain.
People getting organ transplants as well
where they have hungers,
like they have a hunger,
a hunger pangs for something that they
never craved before.
Right?
It's,
it's not,
it's not known as big foot shit.
It is known as as a,
I think it was on 60 minutes.
But I know genetic memory is a real
thing and I just see all of this as part
of the bigger picture as we,
you know,
checking balance ourselves,
constantly improving.
And the left seems to always deny that,
that there's this 45 degree line.
Even in the stock market,
if you invested right before the Great
Depression and you had the patience to
wait 10 years,
you still would have been up.
So all the dips we've had,
it's always been improving,
improving,
improving.
Yeah.
Well there's definitely some memories
that are passed on between parents and
children and they're trying to figure
out exactly what's the mechanism.
But they don't know.
What they do know is that they've done
these studies with mice and it's really
fascinating.
They take mice and they put them in this
cage that has a floor that they can give
an electric shock to it.
And then they release a citrus smell,
that nice smell,
the citrus smell,
and they zap them.
So these APP their feet.
So then these mice have children.
The children have never had this
experience before.
The children are the grow to full size
and then they spray the citrus smell and
they fucking panic.
No Way.
They've never been zapped before,
but they fucking panicked.
They have an immediate reaction to it.
See,
when I hear that,
I go,
how can people not believe in God?
Does it?
Well,
I don't know if it's a god thing.
I think it's a learned reaction to
genetics that passed on from parent to
child.
That is the reason for instincts.
So reason why we have the rational fee
is magic.
It is kind of mad at me for what is that
magic?
I mean,
what is,
what is the universe itself?
I mean,
what is the magic that makes you see me?
What does the magic,
but what does God,
I mean it's a weird limited expression
to to sort of make some sense out of
something that's beyond our feeble mind
and imagination at this point.
I don't know.
I don't know if it's necessarily,
there was an article going around about
a month ago where they said,
we may all be in the matrix.
This could all be some sort of giant
experiment and uh,
I go wait.
It had to have discovered God,
that's what it is.
It's the matrix.
It's the first domino.
It's the,
the machine about God.
You're not talking about a guy who lives
in the clouds with a harp trying to get
a grip on it,
right?
That says drawing a face on the guy.
Like,
like you think it's a gun?
Wilson and castaway.
You're just putting a face on a,
on a baseball glove,
volleyball.
Do you think it's a guy?
Like what are you guys sure guy?
I don't know.
When you trainee if God,
God is a really fat German guy with a
dress and he's got a deep voice and he
eats lipstick.
He's got lipstick all over his teeth.
Man Hands.
He's got a twitch chat all the time.
It's really nice.
Got Chipped Nail Polish on its toes and
just disgusting feet shoved into some
high heel shoes.
Do you,
what do you think it's a physical
entity?
Do you think it's an energy clickable?
I mean our meager of this whole sperm to
human thing because the only
relationship I can see in front of me,
uh,
that mimics this is a pilot is kind of
human being we're the pilot is,
right.
So if you said to a sperm,
so what is this earth man like?
Does he wear a tie and the spring we
just go
that why does the,
those aren't words,
but it seems to me that like when you
say something as God or you believe,
you say you believe in God what you are,
you're defining something but you don't
even know what you're defining
gratitude.
You go to church and it's just about
reverence and thank God that I'm here
and I really appreciate it.
That's Latin mass.
You go to Latin mass and it's just like
[inaudible] like I don't know what
they're saying,
but I'm in this incredible building.
It's blown.
I was talking to Milo,
but at once when he was last in New York
and I go,
it is kind of unusual.
How good to these churches are.
Like how beautiful there do you feel
like when the,
the the guy that the contractors were
making them like the stained glass,
it was like they're on adderall and they
had this sort of divine intervention and
they're like,
holy fuck,
I'm really good today.
I was like,
I can't leave a weld.
It's carvings turning out.
Have you been,
she's described you've been to Rome.
Yeah.
Did you go to the Vatican?
Uh,
yeah.
I think we went up to the wall.
I can't remember if we went in or not.
Oh God man.
You got it.
You want to talk about something that'll
blow your mind as far as like the
religious undertones and the majestic
magnificence of its construction.
St Peter's Basilica.
I mean I,
the,
the whole Vatican is incredible.
The artwork is just amazing.
I mean,
were there for hours and hours wandering
around.
We had this really cool professor we
hired as a guide.
It was amazing.
He told us all the history of
everything.
But when you get to St Peter's basilica
and he was explaining how many hundreds
of years it took to build and they're
building all this shit with no
electricity,
no machines,
no nothing.
Everything is massive and perfect and
beautiful.
It's like you're looking at such an
incredible work of art that's designed
to inspire awe and reverence and the
motivation behind building something
like this fucking hundreds of years ago.
It's,
it's really,
I think it's gratitude and you see this
with my wife's American Indian and at
all those ceremonies.
It's a,
we give things to the north.
Yeah.
We give thanks to the West.
We give thanks to the east and that's
what church is.
It's just like,
I don't know the details,
but thank you for that.
While my hands work,
thank you so much for this.
Let's pray for other people.
I think that's a great way to live.
Life is living life with gratitude and I
try to be thankful all the time.
I'm a very lucky person and I've always
been very lucky and I'm always very
thankful to and I try to be very
generous.
I tried to be very thankful,
try to be friendly as much as I can and
all those things I think sort of build
onto it,
but to have it and define it and to put
it into like a religion,
that's where things can get awry because
they can,
they can get screwy when you're sort of
defining things by this ancient set of
rules.
That was sort of established before we
really understood science before we
really understood,
uh,
the,
the laws of thermodynamics,
the way the universe is formed,
what we know now about the cosmos,
it's just,
there's so many variables that have to
be taken into account when you're
looking at an entire system,
when you're trying to define what,
what God is and what religion is,
and then you look at how restrictive
religion has been in the past and how
many people have suffered because the
discoveries that they had didn't jive
with the ancient texts.
He mean like Galileo and sure.
All that stuff I guess.
I mean the Catholic Church was,
is very pro science and has been pro
science for a long time.
So as the Islamic church for the longest
time,
Islam was like the foundation of science
and the foundation of literature.
Like before,
you know,
like the,
before Gaviscon came riding into Iraq
and fucked up uh,
Baghdad and turned the river red with
blood and black with ink as they said,
like they were some of the best scholars
in the world.
It was like some of the best
mathematics,
some of the,
the,
the best writing.
It had come out of the Islamic world and
they had been conquered and destroyed.
And so much of that was lost.
And you know,
the ebb and flow of these cultures to us
seems like such a long time to go from
1200 to 2017 but in the course of
humanity,
it's a blip.
It's a nothing.
Maybe they're right.
Maybe gays should be thrown off
buildings to pick scientifically proved
it.
Maybe a lot of these rape victims are
bitches that it should have stones
thrown in the fall.
Just kidding.
Internet,
you can't kid,
man.
There's certain things you can't kit
about Gavin.
You know what it has allowed,
thinking about the whole Catholic versus
Protestant things goes back to,
uh,
the ultimate core of all arguments,
which is nature versus nurture.
And the Catholics say some people are
better than others.
Some people are special.
The Protestants say we're all the same.
Uh,
that guy,
the guy up there on that pedestal isn't
better.
And I vacillate myself like you for
example,
are you special?
Are you magic?
Are you blessed?
Like you're on that show why your career
has been so weird.
It seems like every time you get thrown
out of a plane,
we come back a few days later and you've
got a coconut stand and you're wearing a
grass skirt and you're like,
hi,
come on in.
These are where everyone sits for their,
uh,
their coconut juice.
Um,
and maybe you were kind of the Jew.
Judaism seems to say that you're a
chosen one.
That there's some people who are picked
by God,
like that Davinci code thing with Tom
Hanks where some people are just way
better than others.
Like I was having dinner with Sean
Lennon,
but you got to get them on the shelf.
Yeah.
You were telling me one of the most
interesting guys I've ever met in my
life,
but he was,
he's a mason.
Him and Vincent Gallo are masons and
during one of his Doo Hickey's hope he
doesn't mind me telling this,
but there were these like it's so no
snow to roll.
Two guys,
they're looking through like a wood
thing and they invited him to the heavy
shit.
One that's like made a golden is through
a book where you go upside down and you
have to swim there and you've come out
of your workload and your hold like a
diamond sword or something.
I'm just making that up.
Right.
I'm super fancy one and he's like,
I didn't do it because that's not me.
I don't feel like doing that.
I'm not going to go to the fancy one.
I want to be with my boys and I was
thinking later you have a,
maybe you are that Ans Davinci code
guys.
Well this is my take on it.
I think there's definitely nature and
there's definitely nurture.
I think both are factors and to go
nature versus nurture to me seems
simple.
Simple.
It seems too simplistic.
It seems too silly because it seems to
me like your,
you're trying to pick a side.
We're clearly both have massive amounts
of animal.
It comes down to percentages and I think
they've discovered the frontal lobe
where it,
everything matters is 80 nature,
20 nurture.
And we see this with identical twins
separated at birth.
One grew up rich and Paris.
Yeah.
There was poor in Detroit.
Similar dogs.
Husbands looked the same.
Same car.
One does film critic critiques.
The other makes movies.
She's aligned producer.
They are basically the same person.
Hmm.
Well there's definitely gifts,
right?
Some people are intellectually gifted
when we know people that are just really
fucking smart.
They're just born really fucking smart.
They're smarter than me.
I talked to him.
I go,
Jesus.
Yeah.
And then there's other people that are
athletically gifted like Michael Jordan.
Like you can't,
like there's not,
there's not a chance in hell like a take
a Jonah Hill.
Jonah Hill could work every day.
All Day for the rest of his fucking
life.
He's never going to play basketball like
Michael Jordan.
It is impossible if Michael Jordan never
worked out ever,
like never,
like literally just kind of did normal
stuff like everybody else does.
Like man,
went to the gym,
took a spin class,
he could probably jump way fucking
higher than Jonah Hill.
He could probably run way faster than
Jonah Hill and he probably would be
better at anything he applied himself to
athletically because he's got a gift.
He's get clearly genetically gifted.
You know?
Uh,
I think the same could be said of Karl
Malone.
Same could be said of Mike Tyson.
The same could be said of a,
a bunch of great athletes.
Um,
the same could be said of Brock Lesnar.
They didn't,
no matter what you do,
you can lift weights all your fucking
life.
You're never going to be as strong as
that guy who was the mountain drew thorn
was named,
can be Orson or whatever the fuck his
name is.
That gigantic mountain dew guy from game
of thrones.
Like that's a gift,
man.
That guy's gifted 100% and I'm glad you
use sports as an analogy because the
general understanding is there's this
sort of line and it's a gray area and
there's a guy who can throw a softball,
a fast ball at 10 miles an hour or 20
miles an hour and it goes up to 100 and
then there's a guy who can do 99 98 but
I don't think it works like that with
baseball.
I think there's like the 40 miles an
hour people and then there's this
floating bubble of the hundred mile an
hour pitchers and these guys are magic.
They are very special.
They're the Davinci code.
Children of Jesus.
Well in fight and fighting in striking
in particular,
there is,
well there it exists in grappling as
well.
There's strength and grappling that's
like there's some people who have just
freak strength,
but I believe that that could be
nurtured more than striking strength
people when people are good hitters
Stryker's like a guys who are power
punchers empower power kickers.
There's only so much you can teach
someone.
You could teach someone proper
technique,
but power is something that's just given
to you by the great beyond and no one
understands it.
No one knows why you could take two
guys.
One of them looks exactly like the other
one.
They're built the same.
They're both have big muscles.
They both have big hands and one of them
can punch a hole through the fucking
universe and the other one could barely
make the bag move.
It doesn't make any sense and no one
knows why you could take someone in
their body looks completely
unimpressive,
but when they hit people,
people just go flat and no one knows
why.
Well,
no,
I don't believe transfer that hard truth
to intellect.
Yes,
there's this myth that we all need to be
educated.
We all have to go to college.
When my dad was young and Britain,
you did your old levels at 13 and my dad
had a high Iq.
His brothers didn't.
So they sifted through just like a pink
floyd video and they sifted him over to
a scholarship and private school and
they sit at his brother's over to work
in a printing press.
And they all did fine.
They had good jobs and they were,
they were taking advantage of their
skills and then we came with this idea
where everyone had to go to college and
now to lower the bar so everyone can get
in.
We have all these retarded classes.
There's a class at Nyu called 20
something where it's just about being 20
something
done.
Everyone there is 20 something and you
go now you've just wasted your time by
not admitting that some people are
special and that's what I was getting at
earlier with the Western culture thing.
Some cultures are better,
some are more advanced.
There might be a satellite of people
that are just magical.
Like Jimmy Kimmel.
He kept having his career shadowing when
he was in sports radio.
We had this woman above him was out to
sabotage him.
He got sent down the shitter.
Yeah.
What it was.
I heard that story.
What was that about?
Asking him about it?
Some horrible con that tortured him
every day and producer or something.
Yeah.
Wow.
He's so talented though.
Well,
that's why I said that's what I'm
saying.
Like Michael Jordan,
you throw them in Africa and there would
be,
there'd be like,
you'll have to meet this man who is in
the Congo.
He got jump on Minnie and miles.
His name is Juju or Jordan and he has
like a leather basketball and I don't
know what it is.
I am so good at this.
He would be flown over like Jeremy Lin
or whatever and I think Jimmy Kimmel and
you are the same.
They just,
they get fucked over.
I've done it a million times.
I've thrown my career down the toilet
and then I just keep flying through the
sewers and pup.
I come out of another man hole.
Well you figured out a way now
particularly with your show to let your
personality shine through like to like
your unique way of looking at things.
Very thorough examination of the world
around you in an honest take on and that
also happens to be humorous.
But I did that with advertising.
I got involved in advertising
advertising agency.
He sold it for millions.
Then we got fired cause I said shitty
stuff about trainees.
I pointed out they're mentally ill gaze.
Well,
what you pointed out was that there's a
lot of regret and that was where people
were getting really uncomfortable.
And there's,
there's a website,
I think it's called trends,
gender regret.com and there you cannot
tell me that any sort of major surgery
doesn't carry some sort of regret.
When I was in my twenties I had hair
transplants.
I have a big scar on the back of my
head.
You see that?
Oh yeah.
That's because they take a piece of meat
or the back of your head with hair on
it.
Because my hair was falling out and I
was on TV and I was like,
fuck,
if my looks go,
I'm going to be poor again.
I'm fucked.
I'm losing my screen's radio.
Yeah.
And so a while we were on hiatus,
I had hair transplants.
They take a piece of meat back here with
take the hair and they move it all up in
here.
And the way I just,
you know,
it doesn't work because eventually the
other hair falls out and it's just,
you left with this mess.
But yeah,
I regretted it.
It was a stupid thing to do and people
make irrational choices that can become
permanent and if you don't think that
some people who decide that they would
be happier as a woman and then become a
woman and then are miserable because
first of all,
their hormonal profile has changed.
They don't have a penis anymore.
They don't have their testicles anymore.
They wish they could go back to where
they were.
You don't think that that's possible,
that those people who have major surgery
could also possibly have major regret.
That is debt is dishonest,
it's disingenuous and you are,
you are adhering to an ideology rather
than looking at something in a
completely objective and and,
and open and honest way.
You're,
you're using these people as pawns for
your own virtue signaling and it's
murder.
It's like when you see toddlers,
like at that woman's March,
they had these toddlers thing with my
pussy grabs back and you're looking at a
three year old and you're going,
Jesus Christ,
that's child abuse.
And I feel like the,
these liberals are doing tranny abuse by
normalizing such a drastic decision.
And it inevitably,
I know this is the guy you're talking
about.
He's rights for the federalist all the
time and he goes,
what happens with these people as they
have all these problems?
Clearly you're not sick,
you think,
or a woman,
but they also have bipolar and
schizophrenia and manic depression and
all these other things.
They go,
if I could just get rid of my cock and
be a woman,
it would be fine.
Then they do that and for a month
they're happy and then they realize,
wait,
the bipolar is still here.
I'm still depressed.
What the fuck have I done?
Holy Shit.
This isn't the cure all solution.
Not only that,
there's also this,
there's a real problem and that you're
not allowed to bring that up.
Like we know when you look at the,
the the average person,
whether they're gay or straight,
the average people,
men and women out there in the world,
there's a certain amount that are going
to be schizophrenia.
There's a certain amount that are going
to have all sorts of mental illnesses,
depression,
et cetera.
There's a certain amount.
When you start talking about transgender
people,
you are no longer allowed to take that
into consideration and you must treat
every transgender person is if there are
100% mentally healthy,
which is insanely rare in regular
people,
people that are not transgender,
cisgendered.
If you were,
when you use that term,
you look at this gender.
That's what I sent him,
that article that got me and shit.
I go,
let's get the shit here.
Okay,
you're looking at what's his name and
transparent Jeremy,
whatever his name is,
the actor.
Sorry,
when does that,
what is his name?
What does,
the guy was [inaudible] board and you're
supposed to look at them and go,
you know that's an interesting struggle
you're going through.
It's Mrs doubtfire.
I can't not laugh when I look at you.
It's comical and everyone just has this
willful ignorance.
Like I saw Laverne Cox on some dumb day
today show type thing at the hotel
earlier and he's sitting there with his
legs crossed going,
you want to tell the mcbeal?
And so then I was so nervous,
like didn't even slow,
still suck my stomach in.
And you're like,
are we all pretending that you're not a
dude?
Who is the,
who is Laverne Cox was on that show?
A orange is the new black.
I never watched that.
No,
me neither.
But he's a famous Janet mock.
There's Laverne Cox.
They're all the top ones.
It Caitlyn Jenner.
And whenever you see them,
you go,
you're a dude.
Uh,
but a shirt.
I'll sit here and clap and go like,
yes,
you're gorgeous.
Oh my God.
That is a problem.
It's,
it's,
this is,
that's a guy.
Yeah.
Wow.
That's a huge guy.
Is that he a giant.
Really?
Yeah.
And not a guy anymore.
How long has she been a girl?
I don't know.
You never get the straight answer from
these people.
I think he has some pussy out of,
of chopping their dick off she goes.
He thinks well Caitlyn did,
right?
I don't think so.
No.
Oh yeah.
Katelyn didn't,
I mean did pussy out of it.
Yeah.
You get it done.
There you go.
You go girl.
It's a 10.
If there be,
if there comes a time where through
crispr or some other new fangled genetic
manipulation,
you can turn a man to a woman and then
back and forth and you really can be
gender fluid.
Like there's a,
there's an instagram page about gender
fluidity and one of the things it's
like,
I'm not a man.
I'm not.
Sometimes I'm a man,
sometimes I'm a woman,
but I'm always a human like,
okay,
you know,
like,
I don't know,
it may be here.
That's another thing about I'm not a
homophobe,
I'm a homo board.
I don't care who you fuck.
Like when you make out in front of my
building,
have a nice French session.
I don't fucking give a shit with Milo.
And you see that,
I see that sometimes it's black and
white couples.
Like in New York there'll be walking the
chain holding hands and looking
indignant.
You know,
high,
we're in love.
Got a problem with that.
Oh congratulations.
You're fucking someone you're attracted
to ooze.
We to go up there and blow minds,
you're sucking your boyfriend's Dick.
I'm stunned and I think that's why they
get so mad too,
is I go,
you're not a snowflake.
You're not transgendered.
You're just a fucking dude.
Well,
when time moves on and once,
we really do eliminate all the things
that trouble us when it comes down to
homophobia or racism,
all these issues that they're really
still do exist.
You're going to be left with the actual
human beings themselves.
So when no one is transphobic,
when no one's homophobic and no one's
racist,
they can judge you for who you are.
We're there,
but we're not in a lot of ways because
people get free passes if they are
transgender.
If they're gay,
like a guy like Caitlyn Jenner saying
that he's,
he doesn't support gay marriage like
that.
You get a fucking free pass like you're
getting a free pass you,
but here's the best free pass.
The caitlyn Jenner,
God,
she fucking killed a person.
She slammed her car and it's some lady
because she wasn't paying attention,
slammed her fucking escalate and pushed
her in at oncoming traffic and the lady
died and no one brings it up.
That's the freest,
free pass of all took a life by
completely being negligent.
And that's the problem with this bigotry
of low expectations.
You put these people on a pedestal until
they can do no wrong.
And they ended up doing wrong.
I mean that hadn't been Milo to,
he had to get out of jail free card.
He could say whatever he wants and the
next thing you know,
he goes too far on the devil's advocacy
with the 13 year olds sexual
relationships.
And you go,
come on guys,
let's just dial it in a bit here.
We're all the same.
Racism is over.
Homophobia is over.
Let's not sexism.
Racism is over.
I don't think it's over.
I think there's plenty of racist people.
Here's the deal with racism.
Okay,
I'm hiring.
I'm checking out your resume here.
Oh,
you're an accountant.
you want to,
you want to make 80 grand a year.
You saved your previous company 150
grand a year.
Well,
that's a great point for me.
I'm gonna make 70 grand a year just
hiring you.
I'm going to look like a champ.
My job would be more secure.
Uh,
the company will make more money.
I think we,
oh yeah.
Uh,
I didn't know you were black.
you're going to have to leave.
We're a negro free zone,
but you're only talking about hiring.
Okay.
You an hour,
you're sitting there and you're like,
I got my blt.
You didn't toast the bread.
It's like socks.
You just put a sock on a tomato and
some,
and now when I touch it,
it forms in the shape of my fingers.
Like a tempurpedic mattress.
You can't fucking toe spread.
And then some black guys like I fucking,
when they do that,
who has a sandwich that's not toasted?
And by the way,
the giant sucked this year and you feel
the same way about toast,
the same way about the giants.
And you go,
Oh,
uh,
yeah,
I'm going to deny myself this
interesting conversation because you're
a negro.
But you're,
you're being rational though.
Like you're talking about rational
deny themselves money that,
that they don't deny things that are
gonna make them money and people are
selfish,
don't deny themselves.
Cool,
interesting friends.
I think there's plenty of people today
amongst us that are very racist.
What is racist?
Racist is prejudging someone based on
the color of their skin or their ethnic
origin.
So they,
the guy likes all this stuff you like,
but you refuse to see them as an
exception to the ones you like.
Because if you're looking at him and at
the bar,
well that's that one guy and your
scenario.
Yeah.
Well I,
you know you,
you're painting some very simplistic
scenarios that deal with a really
complex issue.
People prejudging people and people not
liking people or people identify with
other people that look like them.
Like you and me being too white guys.
Okay.
The racist you're describing doesn't
like black people.
I'm bringing up a scenario where if he
sees a black person say there is a
racism,
it's like this thin veneer,
oily,
slick in the bathtub.
When you have brill cream and you take a
bath,
all you got to do to go through it,
it just go.
So the second that black guy says,
I hate the giants this year,
that guy's racism just goes.
I mean I have so much more prejudice for
people wear flip flops for men who have
those utility backpacks when they wear a
suit.
What about man,
stay at home dads,
man buns.
I don't think I could be your facility
backpacks and then wear a suit.
Father's suit on put their backpack is
all mountain climb marine with an
ergonomic things and it bothers you.
It drives me nuts.
Why does that bother?
You should have a briefcase if you have
a suit.
But what do you mountain climbing and to
do,
you're a tax audit.
But what is that?
I mean they want to have their laptop
and all their books and they want to
carry it and it's easy to carry things
in your bag.
So find a canvas backpack if you must.
But what's the matter with Karen and I
don't even like when people have rolling
luggage,
we all are growing luggage.
She can't carry 20 pounds.
You Pussy rolling luggage.
It's easy to roll.
Yeah.
So is wearing your pj's on the plane.
It's disgusting to do.
But this is,
is this acceptable?
This backpack?
Yeah.
That's great because you have a tee
shirt on.
Okay,
so your,
your backpack is actually more a fancy
mall than your clothing.
That's fine.
I might not,
I'm not measuring and matching up
correctly.
You're matching up just fine.
But if a young Jamie with his,
uh,
it tech slash comedians outfit,
if he was wearing that and he had maybe
like a certain type of backpack,
what,
what would he be allowed?
What's he got?
Oh,
that seems,
that's nice.
Perfect.
My problem with you,
Jamie,
you shouldn't have anything on your tee
shirt after 30 but that's a fighter and
the kid promoted my friends.
That's,
I'm like,
okay,
I'm doing a commercial.
My friends,
this is my friend John Dudley's.
Okay,
you're doing an ad,
but people like loans on your shirt when
you're 40 or no one cares what bands
you like at that age.
Wow.
Anyway,
my general point is we all have our
little quirks.
You general point is you're very
specific in what you allow people to do
and not do.
Very rigid.
A Guy,
we were in Jamaica on vacation and it
was all you can eat thing.
And he,
he had his plate and he just,
he must've been Irish.
He piled on three huge spoonfuls of
mashed potatoes.
It took up most of his plate.
And I'm looking at him going,
we're in fucking Jamaica,
the jerk chicken,
all this fancy shit and you're using up
your whole meal on mashed potatoes,
you,
that bothers me,
the mic.
And I hated him for the rest of the
trip.
I think I needed someone to hate on the
So I would see him.
He'd just be like eating an ice cream
cone.
And I just go,
fuck.
Wow.
Maybe you do you recognize that's your
own personal issue?
It's a Scottish thing.
Same as the news.
We were at war for 800 years with the
English and they're constantly looking
at the ones who don't like confrontation
or extinct.
Uh,
so Dr drew says this,
he goes,
the reason that Scott's are drunks is
they like,
they like conflict.
So they'll put a war in their body.
So they were going out.
Those walking is hard.
I'm giving myself a handicap,
so we liked struggle.
We like pain.
That's fascinating.
Even in fucking,
I'm never totally enjoying it.
I'm always like,
I got to last longer.
Think of Kevin Spacey.
Do the alphabet backwards.
What do you think of what,
when do you think of Kevin Space Still?
Dude,
it's you think of kindness.
You're going to call me tomorrow.
I'll go.
Thank you so much.
My wife can't walk to that.
You Imagine Kevin Spacey's head floating
over the bed.
Not like dismembered and bleeding,
just like his face doing nothing.
Just staring.
Just staring at you two and a half
minutes.
Do you imagine him as Kaiser San Jose or
as Frank Underwood?
I don't.
I'm not.
I don't have strong feelings about it.
I'm like,
I've never seen that.
A house of lies show her cards.
The card show.
Okay,
sounds great.
Show.
I don't know why I'm in a season three
right now.
Oh,
just started off like you were seeing it
in it.
No,
no,
no.
Intuit.
I talked to a guy who was gay and he
goes,
I'm with Kevin Spacey.
And I go,
can you tell him banging them that I use
him and all my friends do?
And he's like,
no,
I'm not saying that.
That's really mean.
And I had never occurred to me that,
yeah,
you don't want to be known as the guy
who can make you not come.
Yeah.
Nobody wants that.
But anyway,
even fucking,
I'm stressed out.
Even when trump won,
we had a big party,
we were all wearing Hawaiian shirts.
And when I saw Donald Trump president on
the big screen in the bar,
everyone started cheering.
My Buddy Alan was just pouring beer on
his head and I went,
yeah,
cause I didn't want to bomb other guys
out,
but my brain hadn't processed it yet and
I couldn't thoroughly enjoy it.
And then everyone picked me up and
they're carrying me around the bar.
Yeah.
Do you have any problems with him being
the president?
You,
cause you,
you,
you seem pretty,
pretty aware and pretty rational other
than the way you make people dress and
wear backpacks.
But did you have any problems with him
being president?
Is there anything disturbs you about it
or are you totally open?
Like if he starts fucking with the First
Amendment,
I'm going to drag him out of there by
his heels.
I'm not excited about this son in law
getting a job.
That sounds like nepotism
to me.
What a coincidence.
Your son in law is the most qualified
person for the job.
Uh,
there's times when the tweets can be
petty.
I don't know why we're talking about
Arnold Schwarzenegger's a ratings.
Um,
and then,
no,
I'm not excited about the travel budget,
although he is doing a lot of shit.
But as far as what we've come out with
and,
and the amount of fucking left wing
back,
uh,
back patting that we've been going
through for the past eight years,
I'm fucking ecstatic.
What's the backpacking that you're
talking about?
Like they were so wonderful and Obama's
so great and you know,
you,
you come to La and you realize that
everyone in this fucking city thinks
Obama did an awesome job.
And they also think that Bill Maher is
Christopher hitchens.
Like he's an intellectual Demi God in
this town.
Bill Maher's.
Yeah.
Every time I talked to someone they go,
Oh,
you should talk to go.
I'd love to see you in a room with Bill
Maher.
I'm like,
that's your intellectual heavyweight.
That's your main guy.
I think he would probably agree with you
on a lot of things,
which really be confusing to them
because he agreed with Milo on a lot of
things.
So a lot of people are mad at him
because of that.
And you know,
he said that he removed Milo,
reminded him of a young Christopher
hitchens except you know,
gay and foppish and he said a bunch of
other things about him.
Yeah.
But he's like,
you know,
he just got abandoned some of what
you're doing because some of what he's
doing is fighting the good fight against
irrational feminism that denies the
biological differences between men and
women and lies about the gender wage gap
and all these different things that he
does accurately point out which people
it all the fucking time and drives me
nuts.
I've talked about a way too many times
in the show,
but that God damn gender gap was in the
Guardian yesterday.
I know,
and when Obama said it,
I go,
do you know that you're full of shit?
Oh no,
that's not true.
You know you have researchers.
Did you ask him or are you knowingly
repeating this myth?
Because most people don't get votes.
Most people don't know.
It's smart people that I know who have
not looked into it or haven't had
debates about it with other people don't
understand what the gender pay gap
really is.
That it's simply a matter of working
less hours and choosing different jobs.
It's not two people.
One man,
one woman working side by side doing the
same job with a woman makes
significantly less.
And that's what we're being led to
believe and that is,
that is a real sticking point with
feminism.
They're being dishonest in their
portrayal of the issues of the workplace
and you end up going,
you guys are making me think woman are
dumb,
so I don't like that woman's March.
I go,
you guys are,
I don't know what you're out to.
Prove here that your pussy has teeth,
uh,
you're making women look dumb.
Even the abortion thing,
half 50% of women are pro life.
So why are you making this a gender
issue?
It's an,
it's an ethics thing.
It's like a euthanasia,
but it does nothing to do with men or
woman.
Are you okay with abortion up to a
certain age?
No,
not at all.
So week after conception when it's a
bundle of cells,
the size of your fingernail,
uh,
no.
Do not kill that.
Wow.
No heartbeat.
Just uh,
of,
of viable cluster.
A little gals,
beautiful little three cells sitting
there.
You can suck it out with one of those
tiny
cocktail straws you don't really drink
out of,
but they don't do they,
they stuck it out and they want you to
splat against the plexiglass walls
ripped down the side.
Turns out it's good for your skin.
If we can get down to the morning after
pills and that kind of stuff,
I would love to debate to go there.
But right now it's,
it's way too far down the line.
And you know what,
speaking of Bill Maher,
he doesn't have kids.
Angela Merkel doesn't have kids.
There's this lack of connection that
these childless people have in our media
and in our political system.
And there's an anti kid culture going on
that is f no masochism combined with
laziness.
And it really is our death now in many
ways.
Like when I'm in Williamsburg with my
fucking stupid dog that I would happily
kill right now
and will kill your dog,
feel nothing for them.
It's my daughter's dog and it's a little
Havanese puppy.
I don't fucking know.
It's a poppy.
You would kill the puppy.
Well,
if it,
you know,
one of the kids,
I could take a meat cleaver to its head
and I would be on the phone as I did it.
Like we'd be like preparing a chicken
for dinner.
I feel no Jesus.
Um,
and when I have that dog,
all these spinsters,
oh,
what's his name?
Is it in boy and girl and my,
who fucking cares?
He's not going to wear a dress.
But when you're with your kid,
when I'm with my kids,
my son,
my youngest,
my four year old is so cute.
He's a freak.
Like it's,
he's the elephant man of cuteness.
He doesn't,
he looks away from people because they
freak out.
It's,
he's Garish.
She's so cute.
Uh,
but they see them with disdain.
And I've noticed that not just in
hipster Williamsburg,
but you know,
at Fox News,
I would get that from people who didn't
have kids.
Are you sitting at Fox News and you're
looking around the table and you're
like,
we're sitting here talking about family
values and the future of America and I'm
the only person in this entire panel
with kids and I can't help but think
that Angela Merkel suicidal policy of
bringing the refugees and fuck the whole
country is somehow lik linked to her.
Childlessness it may be,
it's certainly linked to her desire to
not come off as racist or homophobic or,
excuse me,
Islamophobic.
Yeah,
it's definitely like their life is
parties and dinner parties.
You don't want things to be weird,
but when you have,
when you have skin in the game,
you go,
I don't fucking care if you hate me.
I gotta make sure that things are kosher
for the boys,
like Dana,
Dana Lash,
she was a feminist raver with big
fucking Ginkgo genes in college and
chain wallet.
And then she saw what a feminism was
doing to young boys and making them
ashamed of being men.
And she had boys.
She went,
Whoa,
whoa.
We created a monster here and pivoted
and became all about saying,
masculinity is aok.
Fuck these feminists.
We were wrong.
You know,
weird times,
man.
It's really weird times where people try
and define themselves now just fucking
breed.
I was talking to some asshole at the bar
last night and he's repeating what he
saw and in all of her stone movie,
and I'm like,
that movie's been debunked,
Michael.
Malice,
no,
sorry,
Michael Moynahan the one about a World
War II and how Stalin was under,
you know,
under appreciated.
And we have to understand that we
shouldn't have gone into World War II
and we shouldn't have fucked with the,
I don't know what move is,
is you're talking about the a untold
history of the world.
I'm watching that right now.
It's read Michael Moynihan's take down
of it.
God Damn it.
I'll just sit for stone is a sale and
really good apologist.
Well he was,
he made out stolen to be a fucking
monster in it.
Oh,
I thought he didn't,
he didn't do enough.
I thought down came out real nice.
Really?
Yeah.
Did you watch the same thing I saw?
Did you watch it?
Yes.
Wow.
Long ago.
When did it come out?
Four years ago.
Longer than that thing.
But a long ass time ago.
But I was really interested in,
but they talking about in all of us
don't have to respond to Moynihan's
take.
Oh,
okay.
Well I'll have to read those.
To what,
what is his name?
Patrick point hand.
Michael Mine the one hand.
Who's Patrick Moynihan?
What do I know that name?
I forget,
but I know that name too.
But,
uh,
I'm listening to this fuck face,
this 34 year old and he's,
he's with this,
we've been with this woman for five
years and she's 29.
And I just said to him,
just stop repeating a documentary you
saw last night and go fucking propose
you pussy.
Did you not know him before those?
This is,
I was shit.
I was shit faced.
My wife and I had,
well my,
and I left the kids in the and Malibu
and we came to,
uh,
we went out,
partied and got a hotel room,
got laid.
It was awesome.
Nice single again.
I don't know how these childless people
are not fucking 24 hours a day.
They probably are.
That's,
but they don't want that to end.
They don't want the fun part to end.
I want to be wrapped up together and
then contemplating divorce.
If you're out there right now and you're
in a relationship with a girl,
you guys live together.
I don't know why she's allowed to wear
clothes in the house the second she
walks into the front door nude,
we'll draw the blinds.
She should be nude at all times.
Don't you kind of want them to wear
clothes so you can take the clothes off?
Nope.
If I was sick,
if I didn't have kids,
my wife would be,
there'd be a basket by the front door
for clothes that she has to take off
when she comes in.
You make her,
Huh?
Yeah.
Noodle lady rules.
High heels.
Only getting a,
or just thinking about it.
Leather underwear.
I would wear leather pants and an
oversized baseball cap.
He comes out about a fluff,
flat brim,
Guitar Player,
Plastic Guitar.
Now how about a Ukulele?
Ukulele too.
And clench shoes,
clown shoes.
Those,
those need to come back.
Actually,
you know what's a hot outfit for Amanda
were in bed is a white t shirt and black
socks and you're just like,
I'm such an ugly pig man.
Spaghetti stains on it.
Just like such a dad,
a big gut hanging out of the bottom of
the t shirt.
I was like,
my buddy Dan goes,
he goes smelling a woman's ass as a poor
man's Viagara cause you're grossed out
by how much you like it and you're like,
I'm a fucking pig.
And then boy,
you know,
young,
young man,
poor man shot by yourself.
You're like,
that's hilarious.
Like this.
Ooh,
what the fuck?
You're sticking your nose in it while
you're eating her out from behind.
Joey Diaz calls that doing the pigeon
piggish and on that note,
should we wrap this up?
Yeah,
let's wrap it up.
All Right Gavin.
Thank you man.
It was fun.
Always fun to you.
Yeah.
Appreciate
times and tell everybody where they can
see your show and listen to it and watch
it.
My show is it compound media.com I also
do a video series on the rebel.media and
I have a regular written column,
a story coming out tomorrow about
milo@tackymagtakitackymag.com and a
compound media is all Anthony Kumina
stuff because that is correct.
So he changed the name because of that
stupid bitch.
That's why you had to change.
And rallies.
He's fucking damaged goods now.
I don't know.
It was still going on.
I thought it was over.
It is,
but comedians are such pussies these
days that they don't want to fuck up
their future.
You know,
hanging out with Kevin can wait show.
Ah,
and on that note,
uh,
we'll be back tomorrow with former UFC
bantamweight champion Dominick Cruz.
See Ya.
Bye.
Okay.